nul autre que fabibi qui me rejoint au
studio salut Fab salut keV salut à tous
donc Fab est-ce que tu peux déjà
apprécier la qualité de l'air ici et
d'ailleurs ça me fait penser qualité
d'air un peu vaste pourquoi fenêtre
fermée je vais l'ouvrir
faut ouvrir on va mieux respirer mieux
commenter parce que parit-il on joue
mieux sur un bien
du coup commentaire était un peu
mauvaise fenêtre je pense
très très haut niveau on voit les
joueurs très heureux oui
mais d'ailleurs est-ce qu'on peut voir
la qualité de l'arche chez eux voir s'il
y a une corrélation entre la joie de
vivre et
[Musique]
il avait pas
ça qu'il a perdu hier
il avait il avait pas mis le
boîtier le boîtier
je t'en prie
aujourd'hui non plus espérons que ça lui
porte pas mal chance
comme il faut
voilà c'est vrai
on a pas alors que Giri
good
20 degrés 52% d'humidité bon bah ça va
très bien quoi la partie a commencé on
est un peu raté le début mais bon on
parlait aussi de choses
quand même
donc il y a les raisins elle est noire
et donc il joue contre Sarana ça
voudrait compris et tout l'intérêt de ce
match faut le gagner pour rester en vie
en cas de nouvelle défaite c'est
l'élimination
on sait pas trop c'est pas tout vert
comme comme
rouge moi j'aurais mis vert quand même
ça devrait être vert fluo quoi enfin en
tout cas c'est rouge donc il te dit ce
qu'il devrait faire un peu plus chaud
chez lui c'est pas assez humide mais
ouais le CO2 est plutôt plutôt bien un
peu sec peut-être
si bonne condition à mon avis je retiens
mieux tes variantes
c'est évident en fait non que tu le dis
tu vois c'est ça qui fait la diff ben
oui non mais parce que bon tu vois on
analysait juste les coups jouer enfin on
sait pas trop quoi mais là quand même on
a des métriques
enfin un grand bon sur sur notre
compréhension de ce qui se passe quoi
tu sens le tu sens l'air est pur
mais ça irraissant on sait pas et ouais
hier il a pris 3-0 bon mais après je
crois qu'il habite à Paris maintenant et
à Paris je crois pas que l'air soit non
non pas très bon mais oui mais oui alors
aujourd'hui peut-être j'en ai de grève
moins de trafic
c'est vrai ça en plus
il peut pas oui mais demain il va pas
être bien non demain si jamais
ça sera compliqué mais on va voir en
tout cas Fab
j'espère que vous êtes là dans le chat
et que vous pouvez suivre alors nous on
va pas du tout discuter avec vous parce
qu'on a une minute trente de décalage
sur vous donc au moment où vous
entendrez ah ben tiens on en parlera
d'autres choses mais mais en soi voilà
n'hésitez pas à nous dire oui ça marche
enfin avec une ultra oh mais c'est sur
ça je viens de voir dans dans le chat ça
parle de grand délice ça serait étonnant
il parle de grande hélice de même donc
ils ont dû entendre ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure en tout cas il y a Isa qui est
déjà dans le dur est-ce que les grèves
ont permis de faire baisser le niveau
CO2 peut-être pas c'est peut-être pas
assez
ça c'est ça tu es mieux jouer en période
de confinement pour ça que ça joue aussi
bien
les gens jouer mieux sur Internet dans
le confinement que maintenant non mais
c'est vrai
les animaux revenaient en ville tout
enfin un air très très simple
alors que là ça suit
donc elle est noir vous l'avez bien
compris on suit côte à les reset tout de
suite un problème sur le pion des 5
Sarana qui a l'air de savoir ce qu'il
fait et à l'IRESA qui suit mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a les raisins il est
quelques petites interviews un peu
particulières
où il te dit qu'il aimerait mieux
travailler dans le domaine fin pas lui
mais tu as des gens qui disent oui il
aurait préféré travailler dans le
domaine de la mode etc et ce qui serait
pas peut-être à lire les raisins en
train de se trouver de nouvelles
passions de nouveaux horizons peut-être
d'ailleurs parce que ça a une belle
chemise peut-être
finalement qui serait bien si hier il
était bien Paramé je ferais plus il est
en deuxième ou troisième division mais
il enchaîné les victoires
peut-être une promotion pour la suite je
sais que ça marche pas par monter des
centres mais
donc en tout cas il va peut-être mettre
des points des puntos pour le classement
général est-ce qualifié pour la grande
finale de fin de saison
en tout cas pas à l'avantage de parram
d'être allé dans une division inférieure
c'est qu'il est peut-être pas bien au
moment de calife mais après il est très
très bien pour la suite
national on va dire troisième ligne
troisième division
il monte
c'est à petit
non pourquoi il y a des capteurs d'air
les capteurs simplement le le sponsor du
tournoi et moi je vais les sortir tout à
l'heure pour la communication
commerciale
c'est magnifique hein
quand tu les appels
et c'était pour si jamais il y a j'avais
laissé les notifs si jamais il y avait
un souci en débutant
tout marche bien ouais donc un c'est le
nom du tournoi en fait le Racing master
de tournoi et qui permet donc de
contrôler la qualité de l'air chez soi
en tout cas elle est dans le dur
et réfléchit beaucoup
et je sais pas exactement ce qui a pu le
surprendre ou pas parce que les Blancs
c'est que des coups très logique
pour jouer etc là ça se voit il est
écœuré mais bon tu sais quand tu joues
plus quand tu es plus super motivé
c'est dur j'ai pas mais moi d'un joueur
comme ça ou si jeune j'oublie hein qui
ne joue plus non l'histoire des échecs
j'ai pas alors peut-être qu'ici remettra
fort mais là on sent qu'il a régressé
depuis quelques mois
le problème oui c'est quand tu tu
joues plus tu pratique moi notamment
l'habitude ton cerveau des calculs va un
peu moins vite les autres pendant ce
temps psy bossent ils sont plus à jour
de ce qui se passe
ils vont jouer des tournois donc ils
font des préparations et forcément ils
sont un peu plus affûtés quoi ils
progresse
et toi tu stagnes donc par rapport à eux
tu regresses quoi en quelque sorte tu
n'avance pas recul
comment tu fais pour être sur place
alors tu avances un tout petit peu
sur la pointe des pieds
il a juste l'air d'être pas bien quoi
après tu peux avoir des cas de figure ou
juste bon tu as peut-être perdre un pion
mais rockevin tu as trouvé des petites
compensations
pendant que c'est bien je fais qu'on a
alors il s'est bien joué contre NACA
mais il joue en bide 103 + 0 Naka
discuter avec le chat mais tu es de la
musique et dandiner comme ça et elle
lireza quand même perdu
puis c'est pas les mêmes cadences là
c'est de la compétition et peut-être
qu'il se prend juste des peut-être plus
au niveau théorique aussi
mais bon comme je le disais ça confirme
un petit peu ce qu'on a pu lire ça et là
sur le fait qu'il avait plus trop envie
de jouer bon de toute façon le fait de
ne pas jouer depuis un an c'est déjà un
signe en fait bah oui oui sinon il
jouerait des tournois est-ce que tu peux
en trouver des tournois tu peux jouer
les lits comme Maxime qui a joué la
Bundesliga ce weekend donc il a fait
petit rock bon pourquoi pas il sera donc
il se développe oui ce que je voulais
dire c'est que les raisons en gros
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait sur une année
c'est les candidats et
la tournée
donc en fait ça fait pas beaucoup sur
sur plus de 12 mois d'ailleurs en fait
le temps
donc oui
après ça c'est un choix personnel il
fait comme il veut
ça c'est un choix personnel mais après
il est jeune il peut complètement
se semi arrêté de jouer à fond pendant
six mois huit mois un an même deux et
revenir plus fort ouais après bon je
crois ça étonnant enfin c'était arrête
tu arrêtes enfin tu peux toujours
revenir mais normalement tu auras du mal
à revenir à top niveau
pour ceux qui connaissent pas l'histoire
c'était pareil un jeune joueur assez
prodige on va dire qui est arrivé en
finale du championnat du monde contre
carpe of en 876
parce que bon il y avait la PC en même
temps mais même en PC final des
candidats il est perdu contre Nantes
donc en fait je veux dire il était
vraiment là dans les trois quatre cinq
mères mondiaux
et donc Mski hyper son match contre
disparition il fait ses études
ces études ses études et je sais pas
c'était en 2005 2006 il fait à son
retour donc plus ou moins 10 ans plus
tard
et
bon il a plus le niveau top de mondial
mais il est quand même il joue à 2750
quoi et il a bien joué il avait fait un
super parcours dans les candidats
peut-être il a fait un match contre
total
du monde mais bon semi quand même et
[Musique]
donc ok il a montré que c'était quand
même possible mais c'est le seul exemple
que j'ai en tête
après aussi jeune il était quand même un
peu plus âgé et surtout il faisait des
études de médecine je crois qu'il a un
gros diplôme
c'était pas juste comme ça en fait
on dirait rapporte aussi bon rapporte
non mais non non
Jules qui a bien stagné pendant de
longues années alors c'est pas tout à
fait le même niveau numéro 120 mondial
et numéro de mondial quoi non et puis
120 et puis c'est même pas une histoire
de stagnostic enfin c'est ne plus jouer
arrêter et juste ne pas progresser c'est
des choses différentes
moi je suis complètement d'accord
après généralement les joueurs
reviennent aussi il faut pas se voiler
la face pour l'argent
bah en fait oui ça peut être un métier
ou un million par an en faisant autre
chose c'est pas forcément facile donc
après
tu peux aussi
tu peux aussi revenir tranquillement
envie de souffler
[Musique]
il a raison nous on aura arrêté depuis
longtemps en fait
donc il file un pion
après il a pas l'appareil de c'est ça on
peut pas savoir peut-être son air juste
ce qui est pas au point
de pollution tout d'un coup j'ai Sarana
on sait pas non on n'a pas non plus en
tout cas
c'est cool
mais clairement bon il va prolon pas
gagner cette partie après ça peut être
une tentative justement d'avoir de
l'activité essayer de regagner ton pion
plus tard et il va faire une petite nul
mais en tout cas ça se passe pas génial
génial pour lui pour l'instant le
scénario
en plus regarde la pendule il y a 10
minutes d'écart ouais je sais pas mais
c'est que c'est exactement la même
saison que les parties d'hier ou en fait
il a perdu 3-0 c'était 3 c'était ça
un peu dans le même esprit
non non il a rien annoncé du tout je
vous dis pas qu'il va arrêter mais j'en
sais rien j'observe de l'extérieur j'ai
aucune info de l'intérieur
[Musique]
il joue ici donc c'est pas qu'il a
complètement ça peut faire du bien après
ça peut faire du bien de faire des
pauses aussi si tu en ressens le besoin
peut-être qu'il a fait beaucoup
d'efforts aussi jusqu'au candidats avec
un moment il se dit ok je souffre je
sais pas moi je suis un observateur
extérieur après il a fait
je me dis ce que je vois mais de grandes
chaises tours ouais jusqu'au prochain
grand ça lui fera une pause de 10 mois
on verra bien comment il revient mais en
fait voilà dans les parties lentes je
veux dire en classique
il a fait ringa en octobre 2021
candidat juillet 2022
singlefield août 2022 et voilà non il
avait joué aussi des il a aussi joué un
truc un peu avant mais en rapide oui je
parle en particulier
c'est mieux de lâcher maintenant que
dans 6 mois
ça arrive mais il a raison
mais bon je rappelle pas dans Magnus par
exemple lâcher non mais deux personnes
en fait mais sûrement que c'est facile
pour personne c'est énormément
d'exigence beaucoup de travail et voilà
et puis bon donc votre moi je critique
même pas en face ce que je vous dis je
fais l'observateur extérieur je vois je
vous dis je vous rends compte de ce que
je vois
je vous dis pas c'est bien c'est mal ça
va l'aider ça va pas l'aider après on
verra bien c'est juste qu'on a pas
l'habitude de voir ça voilà
bah dans les joueurs du top top en
dessous il y en a d'autres qui le font
dans les meilleurs oui oui bien sûr
qui arrête qui font des études qui font
des choses qui font un boulot qui en ont
marre ou peu importe c'est un exemple tu
as arrêté de jouer et puis voilà quoi
donc la Dame Blanche attaquée mais il
contre attaque la dame noire avec son
fout des deux et en cas de faut prendre
quatre il faut prendre un 5 donc on
rentre un peu dans une finale le fou des
4 attaqué donc il y a pas le temps de
prendre le pion en 4 et là donc les
blancs bah
à priori il va faire pousser trois
cavaler prend du coup lequel il sera
bien placé défendra io4 et à deux
et il va digérer son pion alors après
faudra convertir mais c'est clairement
un pion de plus sans vraiment de
compense alors peut-être aller hasard va
quand même pas prendre dans ces trois il
peut conserver son fou
mais cela dit ça fait pas super plaise
avec les Noirs ce genre de position
ce que tu penses qui peut la défendre
quand même je pense qu'il doit pouvoir
avoir une petite chance encore il est
quand même nettement plus fort que
Sarana qui a réussi à bien jouer il y a
peut-être une petite chance de défendre
encore à les raisins mais c'est mauvaise
partie non probablement qui est encore
des chances mais problème ça serait plus
cool avec la pendule dans l'autre sens
où tu mets la pression et
là en fait il y a pas vraiment
bon il est moins bien et de deux il faut
être précis et donc moins tu as de temps
plus c'est dur d'être très précis tout
le temps
qui a l'air assez tranquille
donc là s'il a un des deux joueurs enfin
le perdant de ce match sera complètement
éliminé du tournoi
juste j'ai vu passer dans le chat que
Maxime avait précisé un tournage oublié
c'était le Bucarest qui était en train
de préparation aux candidat pour le coup
un maximum abattu les dernières non
exactement
[Musique]
un peu dans le truc symétrique que
Maxime avait réussi à gagner ouais donc
ça fait ouais ça fait un droit de plus
ok ça va après peut-être les candidats
lui ont fait du mal aussi à les raisins
psychologiquement
ah ouais bah c'est un tournoi plutôt
raté et mais bon sûrement il a mis
beaucoup d'émotions dedans de
préparation d'attente
elle a peut-être eu même la pression des
déclarations de Carlson restez pas fait
directement pour ça grâce à une chose
qui était très honnête en disant ah
tiens j'aimerais bien jouer contre les
raisins nouvelle génération étoile
montante donc c'est intéressant mais
quelque part peut-être tu te mets plus
de pression
c'était vraiment fait marcher dessus
en tout cas en début de tournoi
après il était un peu revenu sur la fin
il est mieux fini de commencer mais
après le truc c'est un peu attendre donc
à partir de mon père de toute façon
tu traînes ta peine
c'est long on se souvient il avait fait
les bullettes les machins c'était beau
ça fait un peu
bon en tout cas il a pris le pion à deux
donc comment il a plus de pions en moins
mais est-ce que sa situation s'arrange
vraiment pour autant on va voir bêtement
cavalier à 6 ça pourrait juste aller
gagner la paire de fou
parce que
de faire tout reprendre à deux et de
laisser les noirs avec une vraie
structure
dommage qu'on suive pas pas
été bien avec les Noirs
il est pas bien là
aussi entourage
il y a peut-être l'effet Niman aussi
pas sûr pour aller Raisa je le sens pas
trop impacté
ça fait de mal à personne
mais prends 5 tu reprends à 2 et c'est
bien joué parce qu'il garde le pion
enfin il rend le pion de plus Sarana
mais Foussais 4 de 3
ouais il va bien placer ses pièces il a
sa majorité elle a le droit qui pourra
avancer petit à petit la paire de fou
avec du jeu sur les deux ailes donc très
bien pour les fous et
donc ouais ça va être difficile pour les
raisins de tenir ça avec peu de enfin
déjà pression d'ici tout court pas
besoin de pendule mais en plus avec peu
de temps c'est limite Mission Impossible
reste quand même mieux qu'hier au moins
on commence par des fêtes au noir
tu es tout de suite
ça après à forcer de forcer au noir
alors qu'il aurait peut-être pu jouer
plus pour nul donc c'est vite retrouvé
mener de zéro là au moins on a encore
une vibrante quoi pour atomiser sur la
dernière au cas où
bon après c'est pas encore perdu juste
il est vraiment pas trop bien et
des pourcentages
j'estime quand même une bonne chance
pour Sarana mais bon c'est pas 100% non
plus
il est il est en loser cue quoi c'est
terrible c'est beau ça
qui est venu quand même
ça trompe pas la looser en fait
est-ce que c'est avec un créneau il y a
3 secondes d'incrément donc il pourra il
pourra terminer la partie après elle est
dur à tenir mais bon il va remettre son
caïd en D6 moi aussi je préfère défendre
comme un resa c'est à dire pas avoir de
pions
matérielle si tu tiens tu tiens quoi
ouais ouais alors ça
disons si tu as des vrais compensations
je préfère avoir un tournoi mais c'est
sûr
le matériel c'est important on a vu une
partie où le mec avait donné sa dame
pour faire mate des fois il faut
vraiment juger est-ce que les principes
sont si vrai que ça on nous ment pas
depuis tu vois que c'est un savoir de
grand maître en fait il faut garder pour
eux ils te donnent des faux bons
conseils en fait elle devrait savoir
c'est que les règles sont complètement
fausses et
est-ce que le cavalier a vraiment plus
de valeur que le tuyau 4 pas sûr il
aurait pu le prendre
est-ce que les grands principes c'est
vraiment pas de la merde finalement
il croit
[Musique]
prends les cases du cavalier
mais bon il y a pas de pions de moi quoi
c'est clairement pas une partie marrante
tu cliques après il va cliquer qui va
partir en C4
mais là parfois tu dois juste cliquer je
sais pas moi c'est 3D 8 et attendre
c'est ce qu'il y a de mieux à faire
moi je suis très heureux quand je fais
ça oui
on va voir ce qu'il fait quoi
tu gagnes c'est pas con
trois fois sur 4 c'est une mauvaise idée
mais il faut la fois où c'est une bonne
idée c'est pas c'est pas si simple
l'adversaire un peu fou
[Musique]
je crois que les blancs
en fait
mais pas par ce tournoi qui rapporte pas
assez
qui stream les parties d'Ali resa et
qu'elle resa et motivé par les échecs
mais pas par un tour il y a pas assez
d'argent comme celui-là il se trouve
c'est le tournoi qui rapporte le plus
d'argent sur la saison donc ça va être
dur de se motiver pour quoi que ce soit
à ce moment-là
je veux dire
[Musique]
ouais mais après peut-être qu'il joue
pour l'argent tu sais il y a des joueurs
dans beaucoup de force ça arrive
évidemment mais c'est pas un bon truc
pour être champion du monde ce genre ça
non c'est bien pour te mettre à l'abri
et passer une vie tranquille mais
évidemment l'argent c'est une motivation
il est professionnel il faut pour ça
alors après peut-être qu'il
j'ai envie de gagner beaucoup vite je
sais pas en fait quels sont ces
motivations mais
en tout cas que je veux dire c'est que
bien joué normalement c'est pas ça qui
va t'empêcher de gagner de l'argent quoi
c'est pas forcément pas compatible avec
l'autre ouais mais regarde nous aussi un
c'est que la Moula
non mais évidemment c'est que
normalement
tu t'en fais un métier à un moment ton
métier il doit être rémunérateur
maltaise
on va voir la puissance des fous
normalement dans la finale parce que
ce que les fous il y a rien de les deux
côtés on voit la pente de kibier 5 620
le pion à 6 saute
je voudrais le rendre D3 pour éviter les
échecs mais ils vont en B3 il veut
peut-être aller à 4 en fait
mais
bon écoute il peut peut-être un moment
de tomber dans un foot que le reposer
c'est ce qui doit espérer
mais c'est dur en fait qui est en train
de pénétrer là là là
c'est un peu le même style bah
d'ailleurs elle a pas fait une très
longue carrière alors maintenant
mais elle a été championne olympique
mais si tu es pas passionné tu pourras
pas avoir une carrière à la magnouche
mais après ce qu'il y a de bizarre c'est
un mec au magasin je crois il met pas
tellement le tennis
mais peut-être que en fait un moment il
s'est mis à bien aimé mais il était
agacé ouais par le tennis
qui est pas mal joué mais bon après
peut-être qu'il dit peut-être que c'est
une manière polie aussi le fait dire
ouais mon intéressé il y a pas assez
d'argent peut-être que c'est une manière
polie aussi de dire autre chose
à dire
enfin
assez d'argent pour les joueurs naturels
il peut y avoir
puis d'ailleurs bon là c'est quelqu'un
dans le chat qui dit qu'il a entendu son
frère
mais bon là je trouve que le la
rémunération danse tournoi là en tout
cas on peut pas trop dire grand chose
c'est pas mal quoi
sur sur le prix et aussi grâce au
sponsoris attention quand même remettre
oui
d'ailleurs il est pas allé vérifier la
qualité de son air oui bon en fait
tu peux dire je préfère jouer en réel ou
je préfère si je préfère ça c'est autre
chose mais pas beaucoup
je serais rien à dire enfin c'est
là on aimerait bien tous à toucher ses
rémunérations là
enfin
il défend ouais il veut essayer d'être
dans une foudre et il va peut-être la
tenir c'est plus sur les ouvertures en
fait qu'il a pas été transcendant depuis
le début
dans le jeu ça reste quand même assez
cool
bon ça donc il y a quand même facile une
bonne option enfin ça mon passage là
pour les raisins ce qui s'est passé
c'est que son pion c'est 5 a disparu
c'était plutôt un pion qu'on pouvait
consacrer comme faible face au pion H2
qui
n'était pas faible du tout enfin c'était
le pire de la majorité donc
il a peut-être un contrôle
tu peux avoir un contre
celle là en posant aussi peu de
problèmes il va s'en vouloir par contre
je suis sûr tu vois qu'il y a les
raisins auraient été hyper motivé contre
un tel que Hikaru contre un tel que mag
nous aussi
s'il joue en match contre Magnus ou quoi
on va le voir jouer nettement mieux
c'était dans ce sens là où tu avais pas
très motivé tu avais beaucoup de
c'est dur c'est tournoi tu vois c'est un
peu la foire d'empagne j'ai jamais
vraiment sûr de quoi tu joues enfin
c'est pas facile non mais c'est dur
d'être tout le temps motif enfin j'ai
envie très très difficile moi-même quand
je joue donc mais en fait c'est ce qu'on
attend d'un grand champion et d'un
joueur qui pourrait éventuellement
prétendre être champion du monde
attention au cheval je veux dire quand
tu vois Carlsen il a envie de gagner
chaque partie mais en fait voilà mais
c'est ça et en fait on aimerait qu'il
appartiennent à stocker catégorie
tu perds une partie tu dors plus quoi
Gary il a fait 20 ans du moins mondial
quoi enfin c'est dire qu'il te fait pas
une partie il va te lâcher ses points et
l'eau ou qu'il est pas motivé quoi il
vient pour te défoncer
et donc en général les voilà mais après
je comprends très bien enfin j'en
souffre moi-même donc je comprends mais
normalement voilà quand un joueur de
l'élite tu voilà ça va
courir je crois que Jim courir quoi je
crois que tu cours pas très loin mais
bon tu cours quand même moi ça me ferait
suer 4 et G5
mais j'ai cinq importants je m'en suis
fait juste trois B4 3b3 il te court la
gueule et après il pousse le pion
et du coup il va courir par là
ça me saoule reste avec moi
D4 c'est 2 3 3
D13 ouais ça c'est gagné
4 avec les Noirs
[Musique]
j'ai la pièce de plus donc attends le
coup c'est roi B3 ici 3 attention et
cavaliers à 4 donc 3 B3
roi C5 3 B2 roi des quatre
j'imagine
tu pouvais passer ton tour de manière
indéfinie tu pourrais pas
donc
roi F4 roi des deux
cheval il y a le roi blanc E3 il y a le
roi noir en G5 et c'est win quoi
que la win en gros voilà
Sarana qui suit quand même c'est dommage
que on se dit allez raisins tu vois il y
a quand même bien défendu sa poubelle
s'il y avait une bonne position un peu
moins j'ai l'impression que peut-être
s'il faisait pas faire une cabille d'eau
et il y avait sûrement moyen de passer
avec le cavalier là-bas
ça devait le faire
alors propose F4 j'aurais même pas
envisagé le coup à vrai dire mais bon a
priori B2 doit gagner aussi mais
F4 EF on va prendre B2 roi D4 F3
j'aurais jamais eu en fait
oui il est pasteur
l'autre ça devait gagner simplement que
j'ai envie de dire mais là c'est ça
tu auras F2 il y aura une dame et en
plus quand tu auras plus le truc du pad
parce que papa
très très bien joué de la part d'alexaï
cas ça c'est clean c'est beau les échecs
quand c'est comme ça la dame machin qui
ferme
permet victoire de Sarana mais jolie
technique en finale ça fait toujours
plaisir ouais tout de suite filé du côté
de Wesley Fab ok vas-y donc on est en
automne il joue contre qui Wesley alors
Wesley il joue
le title
[Rires]
c'est pas un genre de
il a trois sur trois dans le title
les divisions oui en fait il jouit
clique le title oui mais bon en fait
c'est pour ça le soir oui mais ok tu te
dis Baki joue le title ok je joue ok tu
joues le tournoi où il y a Baki en fait
c'est normal
désolé désolé mon Fab ça va clique le
title
mais alors j'ai pas la rêve de l'horaire
non je sais pas si quelqu'un du staff
James comme peut nous dire j'étais
persuadé en fait j'ai même pas fait de
toute façon moi j'ai vu à lire et à 17h
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas de tilt
et peut-être pour moi ça me fait très
plaisir qu'elle
on peut regarder le title quand même
ah mais c'est génial ça si ça joue en
décalé je suis super heureux on va
pouvoir suivre ce temps là pendant 8
heures aujourd'hui Fab
ça peut être assez une genre une journée
tu vois bizarre
ah ouais c'est bon ça mais comment ça se
fait un truc c'est que j'ai pas eu le
personne t'a dit quoi
c'est qu'en fait c'est il y a énormément
de règlement à lire il y a beaucoup de
règlements et j'ai lu les règlements je
les ai compris il y en a vraiment
beaucoup il y a plein de règles et alors
celle-là elle m'a complètement échappé
et oui en fait il joue en deux parties
rapides dans le dans la looser cue ok
c'est deux
ça ça m'avait échappé parce qu'en fait
en winner cue après
classique
c'est de nouveau deux ils ont trouvé une
cohérence dans le truc OK et donc
complètement échappé il t'échappe me et
du coup il commence vers 1945 je suis 45
donc soit le temps de se bien
s'échauffer avec le title et s'il y a
d'autres joueurs genre icaru Magnus qui
quand même tente l'échauffement
ouais c'est la looser cue en fait mais
pourquoi il joue pas en même temps ça
c'est un autre question mais ils sont en
loser cue quoi
peut-être pour qu'on a quand même bien
le temps de voir un peu tout le monde
quoi
bien se focaliser sur sur
le même la même chose la même chose
c'est génial
et du coup il y a que jeudi en fait il y
aura que la user qui jouera j'imagine a
priori
parce que donc si vous avez bien suivi
on a un tableau qui commence en carte
finale donc les qualifiés se continuent
leur route mais les perdants se
retrouvent entre eux et ont quand même
une chance parce qu'il y a un deuxième
tableau des perdants et le vainqueur des
perdants affrontera le grand vainqueur
pour le titre et ça sera vendredi et si
le vainqueur père du coup il rejoint
j'avais pas ouais mais en fait il y a
tellement de rêve à avoir il y a
tellement de règlements
je vous arbre à quatre paloser
c'est trop en fait tu es obligé de dire
loser cue tu peux pas faire autrement
ah c'est beau ça je suis très heureux là
c'est une belle idée ce loser bracket
et
donc ça reprend à quelle heure la
seconde partie de hasard alors hier ça
avait repris c'était pas ça reprenait
pas vraiment un fixe hier tu reprenais
un peu avant d'accord on surveiller les
caméras et on voit c'est ça tu vas voir
quand ça va revenir
ce qui est bien là c'est que
contrairement à League of Legends quand
tu quand tu perds trop en fait tu sors
du tournoi parce qu'en fait sinon tu te
retrouves des loosers de bracket de
loser bracket
totalement leur match quoi tu
peux plus quoi
le Garenne mais bon il fait quoi enfin
tu sais pas enfin le gagne avec son épée
il touche personne mais bon bah non tu
n'en peux plus quoi tu as un Garenne bon
il perd à chaque fois et tu
[Rires]
tu
veux rien faire quoi
tu veux plus carré quoi enfin c'est fini
c'est terminé donc là tu es pas bien
discord allumé pendant la partie bon
c'est terminé quoi
on verra bien écoute de toute façon on
est tranquille ou
donc
c'est éliminer si je comprends la
règlement là en fait la looster
ce truc là en fait j'ai eu la ref du bo2
pour la finale en cas de machin mais
j'ai pas eu la ref
en fait c'est pas quart de finale c'est
bon on va laisser quart de finale en
réalité c'est un peu comme un quart de
finale quand même en quelque sorte de
loser cul donc on va laisser ça comme ça
mais en réalité en réalité c'est pas
vraiment ça ouais pardon non il va
peut-être la gagner quand même oh après
c'est l'armée d'or avec trois
et sur quoi ça donc un peu une tête de
dragon et attention le cahier des cartes
n'est pas emprise enfin il l'est mais il
faut pas le prendre alors pourquoi c'est
quand même une présence
non protégées je prends ouais mais en
fait elle est protégé indirectement à
cause de fou B5
attention
ok alors valeur relative des pièces ou
pas bon mais là plutôt pas là les règles
sont bien respectées mais comment tu
sais du coup aux échecs quand est-ce que
tu dois respecter les règles ou pas très
très bonne question
que je me la pose aussi
bah en fait en général tu suis les
règles sauf si la situation concrète
exige autre chose
pour faire plus simple pour faire plus
ma phrase de plus simple
désolé je pensais que c'était assez
simple
en gros
[Rires]
frère avec celui-ci et il veut me
prendre des tartes dans la gueule
donc on pourrait faire un Tik Tok comme
ça d'ailleurs
[Rires]
[Musique]
dans l'ensemble mais en fait chaque
position auquel on regarde en détail ce
qui se passe très concrètement est-ce
qu'il y a pas mieux à faire est-ce qu'il
y a pas voilà des particularités qui
font que il faille vers
mais je leur séparé dans la vie et
qu'elle soit le sport quoi
c'est vrai dans tout
foot est censé contrôler ton ballon
c'est bon tu as pas le temps tu fais une
touche quoi puis souvent ils font parce
que au niveau des prix parce que voilà
mais s'ils ont temps ils ont le temps
ils préfèrent ils préfèrent avoir le
temps si tu as le temps
mais bon tu choisis pas
donc 1 0 1
et donc ouais un exemple que j'avais lu
dans un livre de nonne pour expliquer ça
non je peux pas le mettre tu peux pas
c'est pas grave mais essayer de
visualiser c'est dur de coup
il y a un principe qui vous dit il faut
pas sortir la dame trop tôt dans
l'ouverture keV ne l'applique pas du
tout mais
l'idée oui c'est que la dame comme c'est
une grosse pièce elle se fait attaquer
et votre adversaire va sortir des pièces
pour vous bouger que votre dame donc bon
vous êtes censé vous développer et ok
donc ça c'est un vrai principe mais si
votre adversaire fait F3 E5 G4 donc le
mode de l'idiot il y a de la mh4mates
pourtant pourtant vous bougez votre dame
au coup numéro 2 qui est pas censé ouais
ce qui est pas censé arriver enfin si
vous suivez le principe faites des cinq
vous prenez le centre parce que
demeurant et pas un mauvais coup mais
enfin quand même
contre-attaque le cahier déjà c'est cool
et puis attaque la tour à la fin et en
plus juste d'un point de vue stratégique
si on démolie F6 on se donne la case des
5 normalement le collo logique serait
cahier 7 pour renforcer
parce que en vrai dire sur fou G7 qui
est le coût d'ordinateur de base tu as
peur de tout prendre et cavaliers
je préfère les blancs
ils vont ok faire fout je sais pas j'ai
5 G7 quelque part F5 mais
on a déjà un petit truc avec les Blancs
enfin on a
on va plutôt faire ça
mais ok au moins
et alors pourquoi choisir E7 plutôt que
G7
c'est pas exactement peut-être qu'il a
envie de garder la défense de D6 pour
une raison qui m'échappe ou qui veut
planter
un cavalier 3 4 un truc tactique
qui est bettera je sais pas si ça va
mais
mais je veux dire j'imagine c'était ça
son idée d'aller plutôt vers 7 que j'ai
7 de toute façon c'est le coup qu'on a
envie de faire quoi qu'il en soit en
fait ouais
je suis d'accord
qui est des 5 tu dis tu touches tout
il faut il vaut mieux la voir sinon
c'est
tu es pas bien là
Maxime qui nous dit un truc intéressant
dans le chat donc bon forcément comme
une trente de retard on va vous le dire
un peu en retard demain mais qui a eu 17
c'est pas génial et bon là c'est un
genre de nageur qui part et donc c'est
intéressant
parce que le Fou est en C8 et il a
galéré à le sortir et en fait c'est un
setup à mettre en place s'il faut déjà
sortir et ce qui explique son choix
mon position
qui a l'air plutôt cool pour les blancs
mais l'ordi donne juste égal
ouais donc bon sur le fameux débat
sur en fait si on a le temps avec les
Blancs on sera bien mais les Noirs
clairement ils vont s'activer et faire
voilà faut que j'ai 5 probablement F5 et
à chercher un dynamisme dans la position
activer les pièces etc
en gros les blancs si on peut garder les
choses dans l'état enlever les dames on
est content
faut-il encore pouvoir
les Nords vont pas être coopératif
bon en tout cas déjà niveau pendule ça
se passe mieux pour les raisins enfin
ça suit quoi dans 11 minutes on 13 bon
ça va il a une position où ça va je veux
dire l'ouverture se passe pas mal enfin
peut-être que se passe juste de part et
d'autre mais
donc on va donc il se replace pour venir
soutenir son cavalier en dessin
alors faut H4 échec c'est un intérêt ou
pas du tout je sais pas ça peut mais
tu crois que j'ai trois
bon il fait tours
je ferai pas forcément mais parce que je
suis pas sûr que j'ai trois ça fait
tellement les blancs
mais
franchement ça pourrait peut-être mais
j'ai trois peut aider à faire F4 plus
tard contre le faux G5 F4 F5 je sais pas
peut-être on donne un truc au blanc
mais parfois provoquer un petit G3 ça
peut
Maxime
et c'est très ok au noir alors qu'avec
le pion F3 qui a faibli il était très
confortable
pas sûr que les cases noires donc c'est
le fond en plus enfin les normes au foot
qui casse noir en plus et donc
[Musique]
ils sont plutôt heureux
ça donne un meilleur socle à la position
pas avoir du quai F6 d’âme prendre ici
en fait il va prendre du cavalier
j'imagine
presque tu vas être complètement fou
comme tu es en majorement
tu vois de base mais là en fait tu es
obligé de gagner bon
ça paraît pas débile
donc il empêche grand rock mais
peut-être on va faire
la diagonale bon on n'a pas dit qu'on
allait pas faire petit éventuellement
d'ailleurs enfin Dame des 3 s'engagent à
rien c'est juste on se donne option
mon frère
je suis pas sûr
bah pour rétablir une égalité matérielle
quelque part peut-être qui juge que sous
va devenir très fort et il peut t'attend
qu'il est derrière la structure il est
pourri il passe devant c'est quand même
une autre histoire moi il me ferait pas
très peur ce fou pour le moment non mais
déjà il t'empêche
la case des deux c'est un si arrondi en
E3 un moment c'est pénible
pour le moment il y a pas péril dans la
demeure
c'est le genre de fou que je connais
bien entre guillemets j'ai pas tout à
fait ce structure mais comme je le
standienne il est là-bas et des fois
quand il se réveille il peut être quoi
au moins il dort pour l'instant il dort
il est tranquille
attention à l'eau qui dort quoi
jamais trop compris cette expression
elle a pas l'air très dangereuse mais
bon on sait pas vraiment elle peut se
réveiller
un torrent ça peut je sais pas trop
la merde
qui peut déborder de faire des
inondations j'en sais rien moi en fait
ok bah non mais je suis pas trop sûr
mais je le comprenais comme ça mais sans
savoir logique
même la même expression en anglais
be Carrefour
je sais pas pourquoi pas
éventuellement des tours un jour qui
partiront
et
ouais
je sais pas je ressemble
mais tu le gardes là tu gardes les cases
noires
avec les Blancs quand même mais en fait
j'aimerais bien que l'utilise 17 sur H5
maintenant
il passe par F6 il se fait dégommer
Robert laisser faire quoi parce qu'en
fait les blancs on va dire alors
cavalier ils ont un cavalier superflu
entre guillemets c'est-à-dire que les
deux veulent la même case si on peut en
échanger un pour mettre l'autre à la
place on est on est très contents
mais oui et en fait faut pas les laisser
échanger enfin c'est pas qu'il est mal
placé en ces trois en soi mais il sert
pas à grand chose quoi il est là
du coup tu sers à rien pour le moment
c'est pas un peu bloc ado avec les
Blancs
et je sais pas trop lequel suggérer
[Musique]
ce qu'on peut faire je sais pas quoi
et j'étais en train de me demander
est-ce que tu peux tenter un coup de con
de type F4 mais ce problème c'est ton X
à 2 tu sais pour essayer de faire prise
retoucher le fou truc un peu concret ok
sauf calculer mais on donne la case de 5
aussi enfin il se passe des trucs mais
le problème
j'arrive pas à trop à comprendre non
plus comment progresser
bon et peut-être je vois pas ce que les
Noirs font non plus non ça va
est-ce qu'on peut faire tourner trois
tours
B3 on va dire de traîner par là-bas
j'en sais rien si si on veut faire ce
plan de toute façon ça rentre dedans
et
bon peut-être un moment on va arriver à
attaquer des six
une sorte de cible
de toute façon si tu veux essayer faut
de toute façon l'avantage avec les
Blancs c'est que tu es obligé de gagner
donc tu poses pas trop de questions
bon tu joues de toute façon et voilà
après pourquoi pas c'est une potion tu
peux cliquer longtemps tu fais jouer
enfin tu es pas mal tu es pas bien tu es
juste ça joue et
tu peux essayer peut-être de provoquer
une faute que le temps passe je veux un
truc
faut voir mais bon je veux faire un truc
dans la pression pour avancer il va bien
falloir faire
un truc comme ça un moment quoi parce
que je crois que j'ai trois rois g2f4
qui arrive jamais hein
ça tu peux pas d'où l'intérêt d'avoir
ramené le pion jusqu'à H4 côté
mais ce fouet en a deux enfin dès que tu
fais cavalier 3 toutes les idées à base
de décalage de cavaliers le [__] à
deux est vraiment gênant
après en deux couilles pour en revenir
mais bon encore que maintenant que la
Tour Eiffel on pourrait dire qu'on
revient par B4 dessin qu'on perd pas
tant de temps non ouais on pourrait
essayer mais après bon les noirs sont
pas obligés de te prendre à deux en même
temps ils peuvent rester en place parce
que si on prend aussi si on met un pion
ils sont contents
en général mais en fait du coup si j'ai
réussi à décaler mettre l'autre cavalier
je sais pas si je suis pas content de
faire un petit jeu de jambes
enfin peut-être même pas en fait je sais
pas c'est juste pour faire quelque chose
j'aurais juste heureux d'avoir fait
quelque chose
tu fais quoi toi
je viens je viens là je reviens là je
viens là enfin tu vois tout d'un coup je
fais des trucs tu tournes quoi pas
après on sait pas trop mais il a fait un
coup
bon au moins il a clique
dans
l'eau des étangs qui n'est pas potable
et l'eau qui est souvent pas potable et
l'eau courante c'est le des rivières eau
potable qui bouge pas donc bon tu
souffres quoi ouais ouais je sais pas si
c'est la vraie explication ou c'est une
explication
tu sens que tu dois pas l'avoir enfin
elle pue déjà quoi
ouais mais c'est pas sûr que les mecs
savaient quoi
qui est revenu
vous le voyez pas mais
je sais pas ce qu'ils ont fait dans la
boîte classement
[Musique]
alors division 1 L 12
qui doit gagner avec les Noirs la
seconde et qui doit prendre tous les
risques j'imagine
il prend des risques donc Thor c'est
être ouais
c'est pas mal
et bah c'est pas bête un truc comme ça
pour gagner
ouais parce que l'adversaire un moment
des têtes ils doivent apprendre une
décision la bonne mais qui fait bouger
la situation tu as pas envie et
peut-être un truc où tu fais des micro
concessions pour essayer de garder une
sorte de statut quo ils peuvent
exactement
a voulu jouer pour attaquer et là tu es
obligé de jouer les coups enfin tu vas
pas laisser attaquer pas bouger quoi
donc c'est pas dur à jouer enfin je joue
ta partie
jouer une partie du jeu d'échec
mais oui effectivement je sais même pas
trop quel plan donner au blanc
c'est beau que il a mis le fond en
dessin ok quoi
c'est comme une petite fille c'est un
peu comme ça
et puis tu as le talonneur qui est
derrière et là le ballon quoi il est là
et il vont pousser quoi genre tu échange
une fois tu reviens enfin
ah mais là on adorait mais le problème
c'est qu'il prend de F quoi si on prend
en fait
c'est sûr si on prend aussi bon même si
enfin on va dire
en dessin amélioration en fait si on lui
échange le foot casse blanche on est
très heureux parce qu'on lui défonce un
peu les cases blanches
noires avec des six seins donc en soit
si on enlève son fout de Blanche
c'est pas speedal pour les Noirs mais il
va pas nous faire plaisir il va
reprendre de F il va bien couvrir ses
cases
donc on serait heureux de l'imposer de
prendre même sans parler de fourchette
mais
pas le faire pour nous faire plaisir
un peu fixé par là-bas
on verra
il fait un truc bien qui joue pas
lentement
peut-être c'est pas trop bon mais il
fait un truc et là tu peux te prendre
une tactique ou quelque chose
bon mais je suis pas sûr qu'il fasse non
plus
mais il bouge les pièces
ouais mais c'est bien ce qu'il fait
enfin
ce que tu fais d'ailleurs parce que
l'autre non plus peut pas trouver ce que
tu fais donc c'est une anticipe pas quoi
ça rend fou parce que le mec te clique
des coups ils savent pas à grand chose
mais il en clique beaucoup et à un
moment donné il y a un truc qui va
vraiment servir à quelque chose mais tu
seras plus sur le qui-vive je me suis
perdu plein de parties comme ça
il fait rien il fait rien il fait rien
tu es tranquille quoi
c'est encore un énième coup de merde et
Tac en fait et tu te retrouves pas bien
mais bon partie
à expliquer en tout cas sur les derniers
coups qui se passe en fait c'est ça
il se passe ce qui se passe rien mais
c'est dur à faire
c'est bien de rien faire et d'être sur
le qui-vive si tu peux faire un truc
dans tous les sports un regard d'un un
Joko des fois
il fait pas grand chose quoi
je fais le point là
je retourne mais oui en fait c'est
c'est un truc fort en fait de pouvoir
rien faire et de piquer de bien de bien
rien faire
[Musique]
qu'il y aura un prix pour le joueur qui
a l'air le plus pur chez lui c'est vrai
que c'est une très bonne suggestion
instant on devrait on devrait proposer
ça prix de la pureté prix de la pureté
c'est vrai que ça c'est il faut écrire à
Rennes c'est une bonne idée pour
remettre en avant la communication
commerciale
à un moment
pourquoi pas
dans la communication commerciale qui
est prévue mais moi je les ai ouvert en
fait
je les ai ouvert directement parce que
j'étais enfin j'étais trop content quoi
c'est la communication commerciale du
tournoi attention
tu peux le brancher donc te connecter en
Wi-Fi c'est comme ça doit être un truc
bleu en plus
j'ai pas réussi encore à les brancher il
faudrait que je m'y mette les ai ouvert
malheureusement avec ma petite fille et
tout ça mais alors celui-là alors
attends
[Musique]
je vais le lire en français un peu vas-y
ça me paraît crucial
introduction d'installation connectée
votre hub au câble d'alimentation bon ça
ok téléchargez ouvrez l'appli RC
ajoutez-y votre hub puis lier vos
appareils
et du coup tu contrôles et tu as tu as
toutes les tu as toutes les infos
mettre à jour synchroniser vos appareils
etc après tu allumes tu synchronises tu
te connectes au Cloud et puis
après tu es bien tu es lancé et
après tu fais tout quoi tu as
l'humidificateur la pompe à chaleur le
18 délicateur le purificateur d'air et
le chauffage connecté donc
et après tu es bien
et donc ouais quand tu te mets en vert
c'est bon bon c'en est compris
intuitivement sans rien nautisme mais
quand même c'est bien de bien sûr rouge
mauvais et quand tu es en jaune c'est
plutôt moyen il faut quand même penser à
aérer à ce moment-là
mais bon par chance c'est que on n'est
pas encore connecté donc on sait pas
trop pourquoi il nous dit ça
mais bon ce que j'ai déplacé il était
vert tout à l'heure et là il est rouge
donc là je suis pas bien
il ne fait plus de couleurs je vais le
laisser là
tu le reposes
toi tu les as pas donc tu as vu il y a
comme un petit niveau pour bien de plat
et donc et donc sur le site officiel tu
as 100 dollars de
d'offres d'aide de déduction de
réduction là c'est magnifique donc ça
vous pouvez le trouver sur le site rcing
il y a les liens qui passent dans le
chat
100 dollars de réduction donc Fab si tu
veux contrôler la pureté de ton air donc
ça c'est une communication commerciale
importante quand même de le souligner et
on va reposer ça je laisse là pour voir
s'il fait un peu de vert à mon ah tiens
il tourne en bleu
[Musique]
je laisse le je laisse l'autre sur la
table on va voir les couleurs oh mais
c'est ça va être dur c'est on allait
partir on a à Nice on a trop de trucs là
bien bien comme il faut
et donc alors il y a plus de dame
sont partis donc plutôt
ce que je disais c'était censé être
profiter au blanc donc bien pour aller
raisin et alors comme ils nous ont fait
ça je sais pas on peut revenir en
arrière ou tant pis c'est le direct
c'est direct mais on peut revenir mais
bon on avait quand même la communication
commerciale juste avant Fab ok donc il a
enlevé son cavalier la dame en a profité
pour intégrer le camp adverse il y a eu
des échanges du coup le fou c'est
replacé sur une autre diagonale et voilà
et ça va remanover un petit peu on voit
il y a eu l'échange des dames et ça
remet neuve mais comme on disait en fait
il se passe pas grand chose peut-être
qu'il y a les raisins à un moment donné
va réussir à faire la différence
par exemple ça il y a peut-être framber
ça j'en sais rien si ça marche ou pas
mais tu vois ça me fait penser à sa
partie dire
et un jouet je te rappelle
et attention une minute à la pendule
pour les raisins contre 5 30 en face il
faut trouver des idées c'est jamais
facile
il va pas un bon match globalement une
nouvelle fois tu as d'Irisa quand même
il y a pas réussi pour le moment à
mettre la pression
il fait une partie mais il met pas
l'adversaire mais peut-être ça va
arriver on sait plus la pendule en fait
il aurait la même position ce serait
Sarana qui a une trente à lire Isa qui a
5 10 je dirais Sarena elle résa fait une
bonne partie une vraie pression il
arrive pas je vais plus vite et plus
tactique que Sarana je pense que il
présente un problème de confiance
bêtement aussi quand tu es plus lent à
jouer c'est ça peut s'expliquer
des coups tant pis en même temps c'est
vrai que c'est une grosse décision de
faire celle-là ça t'enlève le fou
adverse et tu te mets plus en V6 tu peux
devenir une faiblesse
pas mal de choses
et il a joué vite pour faire ça et il va
se faire un truc plus ou moins
imprenable
en fait on a envie de prendre du
cavalier avec les Blancs et de mettre
une tour en dessin qui mais après il va
se passer et si tu fais du pion donc
c'est un mauvais coup mais pour jouer
pour le gains
mais juste normalement enfin on va dire
ça devient un bon coup par la situation
du match c'est à dire que si on parle
que des chèques pure c'est un mauvais
coup parce que on est moins bien que les
blancs mais on a un truc asymétrique
peut-être on va pousser les pions si on
arrive par chance à faire B3 AC4 B4 C5
et les envoyer bon voilà après dans quel
monde
ça va être dur mais oui mais voilà au
moins il a un plan il a un truc
peut-être à faire
alors dans l'autre cas de figure c'était
juste nul facile
il y aura 5 à chaque fois pour empêcher
B4
soucis quoi
c'est dur
tomber 5 ok
la pression à la pendule
il fait une très très bonne partie
dans l'interview hier qui pensait que
c'était
pas très normal d'avoir des Russes qui
puissent encore participer à la suite de
son match
entre entre sarrana à tout à fait de
cette manière là et que c'était pas de
façon pas lui qui décidait mais qui
trouvait que c'était pas forcément
normal c'est comme ça chacun son opinion
[Musique]
un petit tour et puis s'en va pour aller
Raisa qui aura réussi à se qualifier Fab
pour cette première division mais qui ne
va pas passer le moindre retour et qui
s'incline six parties si des fêtes pour
aller résa dans 5 parties 5 défaites ce
qu'il a fait la looser Q qui continue
bon bah écoute voilà illuminé donc ça
rien il va continuer son chemin
peut-être aller voir Google rapidos si
si on a les parties pourquoi pas voir si
[Musique]
arrive à faire son son retard ou pas
cache qui allait son pseudo je ne sais
pas je connais celui de Raouf
mais hier il y avait un bug de pseudo
donc il y avait plus tous les joueurs
c'est quoi ce position ouais il a l'air
de
et on va voir mais
est-ce qu'il y a un deuxième groupe de
loser kunan heureusement non non
tu serais pas bien tu seras vraiment en
turbo loser que des mecs qui ont que
perdu du coup tu tailles que des gens
qui ont permis de la mégalodure
tu veux qu'on te parle le dernier match
du Père Noël super content
tu dois pas être bien
en gros c'est un peu ce qui arrive en
Open quand tu as zéro sur 5 tu joues
l'autre mec qui a 0 sur 5 et
faire ta petite nul au moins il y a pas
d'élimination mais en général ça joue
pas faire
alors que moi je suis directrice
tu changes l'algorithme du coup tu es tu
rentres en winner
bon 30 secondes chacun plus ou moins
bon ça reste une pour les blancs
faciles on va pouvoir faire une belle
pause
c'est bien ça jusqu'à 18h45 bah je crois
ouais un peu
en tout cas on est très heureux
on a fait le déballage commercial je
suis très heureux de la communication
commerciale communication commerciale
voilà
bien vérifier
avant de partir on peut remettre la
petite pub en plus
une pub de 15 secondes
peut-être qu'il est pas non plus hyper
motivé pour ses tournois il s'est un
tournoi de reprise complètement sur
Internet enfin ça veut rien dire en fait
il y a vraiment mal joué mais aux
candidat quand il était pas en confiance
il avait aussi enchaîné dans un moment
donné les parties vraiment
de piètre qualité et puis c'est terminé
on n'a pas le temps de suivre toutes les
divisions peut-être que je sais pas si
étant winner on loser cute deuxième
division
de la troisième division il doit pas
être bien
[Musique]
c'est pas sûr
ouais enfin il tente
après je crois qu'il y a pas du tout de
perpète en fait
ouais
cette dame c'est incroyable à 6 ouais
bon en fait il est pas bien Google
[Musique]
mesdames
merci au revoir
il a fait le petit il est content
elle a pris le risque il a fait ce que
il a pas l'air bien Google
[Musique]
on peut le prendre en photo
très dur
j'aurais jamais trouvé
bon exercice avec le temps pourquoi pas
mais là avec le peu de temps qu'il a
jamais et je serais même pas entendre la
position et en particulier
je m'arrête je cherche pas à trouver
un autre mais
tu rentres là-dedans de gâté de cœur
et il y a perfect je fais une il peut
perpète j'ai perdu on verra bien quoi
après peut-être c'est un mauvais truc
c'est de pas avoir fait dame B8
dame C7 madame prend B7 mesdames c'est
ça tu reviens sur la colonne D si il
couvre avec la dame c'est peut-être là
en fait l'erreur
comme ça en fait c'était simple
tu es jamais bien en fait non je déteste
[Musique]
vas-y est-ce que je vais écouter mais ce
qu'on a le son non non
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez bien kiffé ces
petites pubs ont envoyé deux donc après
on fera une petite pause après le
l'Armageddon voilà avant le
winner
un truc comme ça
[Musique]
je suis très heureux de toutes les pubs
qu'on a mis
après je suis juste déçu parce que là la
communication commerciale pour montrer
le petit truc c'est que une fois on peut
pas refaire on peut on peut faire
plaisir
on n'est pas obligé mais on peut le
refaire on le refera je pense
peut-être le renvaler et le
scotch un peu
le refaire quoi
une deuxième fois
avec de la surprise et tout
on sait plus trop quoi dire hein on
attend je sais pas quelle heure ils font
leur enchères
donc le principe des enchères c'est que
c'est un Armageddon donc
de toute façon les blancs doivent gagner
sinon ils ont ils sont mis du match ou
des blancs auront plus de temps que les
Noirs voilà ça c'est la règle la règle
de base donc d'habitude c'est du Blitz
donc c'est 5 minutes 30 4 6 minutes
contre il y a plusieurs trucs là
en fait ils vont juste donner les blancs
au plus offrant qui dit moi je suis prêt
à jouer avec 5000 de retard ou je sais
pas quoi etc
en tout cas celui qui accepte qui fera
le plus gros enchères
le décalage oui oui s'il y a toujours le
décalage
d'une minute 30 donc c'est pour pas que
les joueurs puissent éventuellement
avoir le stream quoi
donc on attend je sais pas trop comment
ça va repartir
non je sais pas bon je pense ça pas trop
tarder on va sur les caméras de contrôle
que
je reçois en place
ils sont dans leur caméra
refaire bouillant il se lève il sera
soit
un truc comme ça en fait sur les très
heureux de le recevoir
ok plus sérieux enfin je sais pas moi
expressif en tout cas très focus
fidèle à lui-même
très sympa
c'est pas trop
mais on pense que c'est incessamment
sous peu quoi
à quel point
c'est pas
quoi là ils sont on attend en Armageddon
en fait mais après c'est tournant un peu
compliqué en fait à comprendre les
règles donc c'est très difficile de
t'expliquer tu es pas tombé sur le temps
le plus simple en tout cas on attend une
partie où les Blancs seront obligés de
gagner pour rester dans le tournoi mais
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de règles non
c'est pas encore qui aura les blonds pas
c'est ce qui décide ouais voilà donc en
cas de partie nulle qualification des
Noirs en tout cas de victoire des Noirs
qualification des Noirs aussi évidemment
et voilà on n'a pas le choix ils seront
dans l'obligation de
les enchères je sais pas
vraiment les connaître mais c'est un peu
long je trouve
ces deux parties
avant le match en fait ouais c'est vrai
on arrive au truc comme ça on clique
après ce que tu as bien mis ensuite ou
quoi
après
tu as bien fait de le dire mais après de
toute façon avec les caméras ne vous
inquiétez pas on va pas manquer
on voit qu'ils sont pas là en fait pour
faire simple ça joue pas
mais pour le coup pour les enchères
en tout cas ça doit être court puisque
la finale ça commence à 18h45 et je
pense pas qu'il retarde
il est parti de la phase finalement on
fera une petite pause après
malheureusement on ne savait pas à
quelle vitesse ça allait reprendre
dans la poule des vainqueurs ça sera un
match assez long en quatre parties et
peut-être plus si affinités s'il y a
deux il y aurait aussi
le fameux Armageddon avec enchères et
compagnie
ça parle ça fait un petit tour dans la
cam
un petit tour et puis s'en va
j'ai pas j'ai pas réussi à voir il y a
plein de sponsors certains j'ai vu chez
sarahma tout ça me tape j'ai pas regardé
ce que c'était c'est un sponsor en tout
cas du tournoi
je peux chercher
en tout cas c'est beau
il y a des beaux
mais c'est pas encore parti
encore un autre truc
j'en ai regardé après j'en ai certains
j'en ai je les ai oublié
en tout cas ça nous fait des beaux live
des belles soirées
matchs trépidant animaux
pense que le temps noir était ajouté à
11 ouais donc c'est ce que je te disais
ouais c'est du 15 minutes quand même
l'Armageddon c'est la même cadence et
donc ouais tu vois je me suis pas trompé
mais après ça me paraissait bizarre donc
j'étais moins sûr ça reste de pas être
évident de finir à 18h45 alors histoire
non mais ça a peut-être commencé un
petit peu en retard de les autres matchs
à 19h
donc une slave comme tu les aimes bien
toi
être assez terrible pour fille alors je
pense pas je crois qu'ils sont un petit
peu pour te dire la vérité je pense pas
que
ça a dû me saouler de perdre évidemment
mais bon
ce que donne cette Armageddon donc les
blancs sont obligés de gagner et c'est
plutôt un bon début de partie pour Raouf
je dirais parce que la position elle est
quand même assez symétrique et dans une
position que tu dois faire nul je dirais
que ça se passe plutôt bien pour le
joueur
azéri qui arbore le drapeau de l'Ukraine
à côté de son pseudo
c'est vrai que c'est un triple
élimination il rejouerait le perdant
contre agir ça se fait un triple
élimination
boire du coup
je sais pas pourquoi
je l'ai pas considéré comme une réponse
là
toutes les parties que j'ai vu il y a
pas de
la partie qu'on a compté ce matin
dire que il est parti sur lesquels on
est tombé qu'on a regardé
on n'a pas vu une belle partie avec
ça
avec des des belles rencontres il y a
Magnus qui qui rentre en piste on a
l'affrontement entre peut-être car oui
Wesley aussi
de toute façon ça compte pas pour les
lots ça compte pour rien donc à bon
c'est juste voilà pour que la son
général de ce tournoi ça part pas super
bien de faire que des effets j'imagine
après je sais pas exactement comment ça
marche ouais il y a un comptage de
points mais oui tu marques là quand tu
perds
[Musique]
tu marques pas énormément de Punto
j'imagine enfin non mais tu es quand
même en première division donc par
rapport au mec qui crache mais tu gagnes
moins là c'est sûr qu'il gagne moins que
celui qui gagnera la division 2 ou 3
maintenant ou pas je crois que tu es
quand même au dessus mais que deux tu es
pas très bien ouais
il va jouer contre bien favori
je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'on suit après
en principal on regarde la formation
ouais mais bon
depuis le début j'ai envie de limiter
les les chances maintenant
il y a quand même du saut dans le règne
ça je vais lui demander tiens maintenant
normalement oui après faudrait que le
temps à se finit sinon on va devoir
regarder après j'imagine que vous
préférez quand même largement le ring
master c'est un simple title Tuesday
entre guillemets ce serait quand même
dommage de préférer le title
petit à petit j'ai l'impression qu'il se
fait un peu bouffer de l'espace avec les
noirs
HC1
pour rester d'aller voilà attaquer un
peu petit à petit
un rafle qui joue un peu contre nature
cette partie il a déjà joué
on le voit plus on met des petites
externes des trucs et là il sait qu'il
est nul peut lui suffire il joue un truc
plus calme mais
pour son style capable de tout à ouf
un type très sympa Raouf c'est plus
notre génération que que dommage
même si dommage c'est un beau joueur
forcément on a un petit faible pour
qu'on connaît déjà de l'époque on jouait
les championnats du monde jeune on le
croiser déjà
avec ma mère
ça c'est un peu assagi quand même avec
l'âge comme tout le monde
plus la même énergie aussi
je trouve quand tu joues en 15 minutes
de refaire l'armée dans 15 minutes ça me
paraît hein
[Musique]
on avait déjà trouvé que c'était bizarre
mais c'est peut-être la nouvelle manière
de faire c'était quoi
ton Norvège ou
non Norvège
mais il joue en longue de base
c'était c'était
bien parce qu'en fait la mode avant à
notre époque où nous on joue en tournoi
entre guillemets plus sérieusement même
si toi tu as pas complètement arrêté
mais les Armageddon c'était
systématiquement des cadeaux
ouais et souvent quasiment que du Blitz
c'est un peu comme les tirs au but
trois fois plus court
alors que dans le match on a quatre
après ça se discute mais ouais en taille
break c'est en 7 points quoi c'est pas
toujours pas cette
il faut un taille-haie 11 points mais
ils refont pas la rigueur
c'est un peu étonnant mais écoute c'est
la nouvelle mode il faut s'adapter il
faut vivre avec son temps
change de cadence à Saint-André de
partir rapidement
pour dire oui non c'est mieux comme ça
mais clairement voilà c'est plutôt
nouveau on n'est pas l'habitude que
l'Armageddon c'est pas comme ça c'est
des nouveautés Fab il faut faire évoluer
le jeu c'est des bonnes choses tout ça
on va dire
[Musique]
faut pas évoluer pour évoluer ouais mais
là on évolue
du coup B4 probablement faut le prendre
en passant sinon en fait on va se faire
entourer le pion C4 non il va mettre le
client C5
et la tour on va pas défendre donc
c'est beau les échecs quand c'est jouer
comme ça
[Musique]
pour Param
ça serait dur pour pas
il serait pas bien
c'est ça qui veut mettre son cavalier en
dessin et contre-attaquer B4 et pousser
ses trois et je sais pas enfin il a pris
ce parti pris là quoi
qui est pas un mauvais parti pris voilà
après je sais pas si c'était mieux de
faire l'autre avec la prise en passant
en fait moi c'est pour te faire la
vérité j'ai calcu une variante avec qui
il prend à 6 je me disais oui on peut
peut-être bouger la tour faire C3
récupérer B4 et en fait j'avais pas du
tout oursin qui est le coup main de
l'ordi qui est extrêmement bien joué
de goût cash qui te bloque le pion c'est
qui veut tout le manger et sur quel
prend B4 il veut prendre en C4 puis
prendre à 6
[Musique]
je pense que tu es obligé tu as
peut-être une chance mais mais attention
on se casse à faire français 5
c'est pas facile
ouais
tu as pas le choix
il va réussir à faire un blocus Fab
on va voir
ce que tu rejoues contre un mec enfin un
potentiellement il a perdu contre qui il
a perdu Naka ouais
Naka il rejoint le même adversaire sauf
que lui serait dans une winner cue
puisqu'il vient de gagner alors que il
vient de perdre un peu en looser que
donc
par rapport aux algo machin tu vois
ça peut turbo trop là à côté tu vois
ouais bon là il est pas bien je pensais
qu'il réussit il réussir à prendre ses
seins et écrire un blocus
en quoi il peut il peut se retrouver
dans une dynamique difficile
en tout cas quel magnifique spectacle
l'Armageddon c'est toujours assez
impressionnant mais là qui a eu des
trois très bien
d'ailleurs il en a que une autre ouais
c'est
ça va être compliqué pour Raouf
le 5 et français 4 regarde cette
tourelle en 6 bien placé la tour qui se
fait retoucher elle va repartir et
peut-être il va y avoir du G4 4 5
c'est petit à petit bon c'est pas encore
gagné mais c'est bien
très bien pour les blancs
faut appeler le papa tango allô papa
tango ici en Slimane
ça va qui écrit ça c'est magnifique en
fait
tu es pas bien
le papa tango
[Musique]
allô
il chante vite fait mais je sais plus
trop ce qu'il dit quoi qui sont ils sont
sûrs dans l'avion non
je sais plus trop ce qui se passe quoi
en tout cas la position
qu'elle viendra en C4 sera un F4 sera
terminé
et tu as peut-être juste pas de coup en
fait
beurk
parade mais tu attends
c'est même pas si simple à gagner encore
non mais nul leur suffit
même en filant une pièce comme ça
donc on nous redemande escale tahital
avec Baki et non le 15 de France
peut-être
un tournoi qui est au dessus du title
c'est quand même qualitatif merci master
quand même au dessus enfin
est-ce qu'il y a les raisins à jouer
aujourd'hui oui il s'est fait éliminer
du tournoi il avait perdu son premier
match rappelle et là du coup sa deuxième
vie dans le tournoi qui qui s'est effacé
et voilà donc là il est vraiment éliminé
pour de bon
allez on est en train de vivre
l'élimination de Raouf mamedov
il fait attention Google parce qu'on le
rappelle c'est l'Armageddon donc une nu
qualifierait ma médoff
faut pas échapper la proie c'est terminé
mais bon pour l'instant la proie est
bien bien attrapé surtout qu'il a de
moins en moins de temps à ouf il va
passer sous les 3 minutes
qui termine
de terminer
je pensais qu'elle serait décalée c'est
pour ça que je les ai pas parce qu'on
avait donné l'horaire de 18h45 donc
là menace 5 mains en un menace fouger 5
il y a trop de menaces il a pris il va
déjà perdre le four
voir plus si affinités
aussi d'ailleurs au passage
merci au revoir
donc là ça va être la qualification de
Google bon plutôt mériter je crois sur
l'ensemble du match on n'a pas vu la
première partie mais qui a gagné la
deuxième il était bien c'est un peu auto
arnaqué à la fin et là il a bien
maîtrisé le l'armée donc
il emporte
donc on va faire tout de suite une pause
après cette partie là parce que sinon
[Musique]
on nous dit je vais remontrer je sais
pas si il décalage mais fougait 5 échecs
la case F7 est obstruée Roy F5 et G4
merci au revoir
là tu as beau réfléchir côté Raph ma
mère il y a pas de solution
il pourra s'il le souhaite un
s'organiser un match amical contre
aliasa ils peuvent se contacter entre
je suis pas sûr
de moi
tu remontes et tu refais des matchs
amicaux avec les autres qui ont gagné
qui va devoir
une minute avant accepter les gens
il y a même pas un dernier piège voilà
tu peux même pas faire un E3 ou une
embrouille à ton rêve cet matin
quoi qu'il en soit
et par la pendule je pense que même si
il avait un coup de défense là pour
jouer un peu plus il aurait juste pu
assez de temps et il abandonne
éliminé donc nous on part en pause très
rapidement et on revient dans un petit
quart d'heure j'imagine que ça va
commencer vers 19h
à tout de suite les amis je renvoie une
pub après
[Musique]
les amis on est de retour
on est de retour ça pas encore commencé
attends on va voir les cames qu'on a
alors on regarde quel match on regarde
le match de Carlson tiens mais on va
faire le on va laisser car c'est un cap
pour le moment à gauche et on va vous
demander
quel match vous préférez voir est-ce que
vous préférez voir Naka contre so ou
Carsen contre irigalisive
et on fait un vote dans le chat on va
avoir on va les laisser un peu écrire ou
alors on peut lancer le vote au monde on
n'aura pas le décalage pour le vote on
n'aura pas le décalage
[Musique]
on va laisser deux minutes
on mettra le setup les bonnes caméras
exactement Fab
imagine il y a de décalage pour le vote
aussi non c'est bon
après on fait ce qu'on veut genre s'il y
a du monde qui regarde au nombre de
votants qu'on va avoir
il faut qu'ils aient l'habitude de voter
ouais mais bon on si tu as pas au moins
200 300 personnes sur un web comme ça
c'est que il y a plus grand monde
on va voir peut-être qu'ils sont
endormis
pendant la pause
bonne tendance se dessine je vous dis
pas laquelle
on voit les joueurs qui se préparent
c'est beau car le 5 il y a tout un tas
de tous ces sponsors mais toi tu as
Unibet Puma
c'est beau en fait c'est un il peut
ouvrir
un pilote de Formule 1 quoi
c'est beau
donc il est il est à Montréal donc pour
jouer ce temps
on va voir Magnus il s'est mis du bon
côté de la caméra vers le bas
mais pratique en termes de placement bah
du coup comme on voit on va tout de
suite mettre 0 0
est-ce qu'on a la qualité de l'arche
chez Magnus non
ça va bien
je crois qu'il joue pas en fait
mais c'est d'autant plus beau en fait
qui joue pas
son truc
donc voilà clairement le vote est
terminé donc vous avez choisi de voir le
match de Magnus contre
4% d'entre vous
et on a eu 92 votants
donc
Erika ici
je sais pas qui commence à quelle
couleur on verra ça devrait pas trop
tarder toujours est-il
donc ici on rappelle qui a battu
largement fier 3 0
large succès alors finalement à l'IRISA
qui a
lui perdu
c'est pas qu'il a pas encore c'est qu'il
rejouera pas mais il y a même pas eu une
nul dans le tournoi en fait
oui
j'en ai rien
en fait il joue ah ça y est ça vient de
partir
et donc Magnus allez blanc et une petite
anglaise
et voilà c'est parti
ça joue la symétrie et donc Magnus qui
doit hésiter sur son setup bon souvent
c'est défiant keto mais il peut aussi
jouer bien sûr ici
en même D4 un coup
je pense que Karlsen est énorme favori
contre il y a ici je pense que Erika ici
tu vois il aurait joué contre un joueur
un peu moins fort il aurait beaucoup
mieux joué je pense que là il va avoir
plus de
difficultés à
développer son jeu je pense contre
contre Carlsen et Naka je pense qu'il
aurait pu plus facilement élever son
niveau de jeu contre un autre joueur
bon c'est vrai que c'est dur je compte
Carl scène de toute façon juste par la
pression psychologique qu'il impose son
aura et tout ça mais non c'est deux
joueurs généralement qui sont plus
compliqués à maîtriser à gérer
mais je pense qu'il va avoir énormément
de mal
on verra
en tout cas l'avenir nous le dira à
rendre on aura la réponse à cette
question
dans 4 heures Fab exactement et non mais
il dit en tout cas qui commence à
s'installer petit à petit dans cette
caste de joueurs j'ai envie de dire qui
a fait connaissance un peu dans les
tournois l'an dernier à viscanzi il est
bien commencé il était solide puis bon
comme il a perdu pas mal de partir en
deuxième moitié de tournoi
mais c'est bon pour l'expérience et mon
rappel qui est tout jeune il a 19 ans
donc
encore en phase d'apprentissage mais
ça joue pas mal et il en oui non
winner
il ne serait pas éliminé du tournoi les
joueurs que que l'on suit là dans cette
fin demi finale mais qu'on pourra
appeler un quart de finale finalement ce
qui est encore 3 matchs à gagner c'est
un peu dur d'avoir la fellation exacte
mais en tout cas les joueurs qui qui
sont là
ils sont là voilà
il sera encore là demain contrairement
au match d'avant
il y avait le coup près et si gagne
aujourd'hui et quand il joue demain la
finale bah ceux qui perd la finale il
sera quand même encore là
à un moment donné
pour rejouer la finale de la looser cue
et peut-être pour rejouer la grande
finale en winner
qui sera en winner cue donc si il perd
et ben il aura le bonus
et c'est ça qui est beau quand même
globalement c'est pas perdu deux fois tu
es là quoi mais en fait ce qu'on appelle
un double élimination
c'est beau
donc en gros c'est une sorte de
sicilienne inversé la position
très bizarre
bon
contrôle la grande diagonale
mais là
mais c'est magnifique il a gagné le
title il a quand même terminé le timer
[Musique]
oui bon peut-être qu'on est pour ça en
fait quelle taille tu as l'avant
beaucoup plus intéressant et après il
joue le truc
contre Naka
il est tellement heureux
5 dame 4 qui est français 3
n'est plus sur échec le cavalier de ces
trois et on a une pièce de main
je serais tenté de trois bâtiments avec
les Blancs enfin bêtement c'est pas on
veut sortir le fou quoi et naturellement
on va dire
c'est beau E3 je vais d'ailleurs
ça c'est le title en fait qui est un peu
retardé le truc en fait
c'est quand même spécial
un échauffement quelque part mais c'est
vrai qu'on a pas l'habitude tu vois quoi
de France d'aller voir faire un petit
critérium le matin avant l'étape du jour
ouais pourquoi pas après pourquoi pas ça
chauffe les jambes après tu les vois un
peu tourner les gens sur sur les vélos
comme toi tu vas faire à partir de la
semaine prochaine d'ailleurs tu vas pas
être bien mais ouais
mais c'est c'est un très beau tournoi
auquel on assiste je rappelle c'est le
circuit de l'année le plus doté c'est là
où il y a le plus d'argent c'est là où
les joueurs vont se donner à fond
sur ce tournoi
[Musique]
quelque part
qui pour arriver donc les blancs leurs
plans essayer de casser tout ça soit en
faisant un beau D4 à un moment ou à
trois B4 en terme de structure pion et
sinon j'imagine que Magnus va plutôt
essayer de développer le fond des trois
pour ça sûrement qu'il a mis ça dans mon
B1 pour se jouer le contrôle des cases
blanches avec un fond Detroit qui
pourrait aller viser vers H7 qui peut
revenir peut-être vers 4 un jour quelque
chose comme ça
un truc stratégique qui en est va pas
trop cette offre français 6
mais tu peux toujours poser la question
à te dire tiens je double les pions du
coup E5 devient faible et je préfère
qu'il y avait ou A4 et mes pièces
plantes sur la colonne c'est mais bon on
se défonce les cases blanches quand on
fait ça c'est hyper dangereux
bon faut vraiment le faire genre si ça
marche vraiment bien quoi
complètement
quand j'ai dit ça
j'ai pas dit grand-chose quoi
c'est les quarts de finale mais en fait
j'ai pas trop comment appeler ça ça le
problème c'est pas vraiment des quarts
de finale mais c'est pas des demi non
plus
bon c'est pas non plus enfin c'est pas
comment est-ce que
deuxième tour de la Ligue 1 winner
4 après
je sais pas
bon
pour pousser ou C4 et essayer de gagner
contre le dessin pourquoi pas
tu prends du pion pour remettre le fond
C4 et te doubler les pions
ça demande beaucoup de choses mais
si tu arrives sur ces deux trois dessins
chez lui c'est son club c'est un club
non
c'est une tête de club mais après ça il
y a que un échiquier derrière lui en
fait je sais pas alors il est pas super
bien cadré en fait un peu mieux le
mettre j'avais pas remarqué en fait
c'est un peu décalé et j'ai pas remarqué
sur un truc j'ai remarqué toujours
l'impression qu'ils sont les endroits un
peu bizarres alors qu'ils sont vraiment
blindés de chez blindé
des joueurs indiens gèrent leur décor de
fond sont souvent un peu peut-être c'est
la mode
c'est ça qui sont hyper blindés là-bas
c'est très bien vu ils ont beaucoup de
sponsors et des prices pools qui gagnent
même dans leurs open
ils sont vraiment très très riches
nationales ça c'est très bien
très bien vu des genre d'échec en Inde
ce qu'on appelle une bonne situation
je crois qu'il y a pas de bonne ou de
mauvaise situation non mais peut-être
que là si bon
tout des rencontres
c'est sûr et des opportunités
c'est très bien
ça me fait penser que je suis pas
[Musique]
j'avais espoir sur le nouvel Astérix
mais du coup je suis pas allé le voir
c'est juste un défilé de guest et que du
coup ça pourra faire de la vue parce que
il y a les jeunes qui vont bien aimer
quelqu'un des idoles voilà mais en soi
je crois que c'est pas ça on n'est pas
le public visé quoi on va dire
que ils ont pas de bol dans le sens ça
se compare un peu à Mission Cléopâtre ah
non mais non
c'était vraiment bien
il y a beaucoup de petits gags marrant
en fait non
il est blagues étaient pas forcément
hyper attendues non c'était pas forcé
c'était franchement de parler je joue
très bien Obélix
alors clavier je sais pas enfin là pour
le coup
mais en tout cas ça allait
et puis il y avait plein d'autres
acteurs autour plutôt pas mal des petits
gars ici ou là
c'est bien ce qu'il fait minus c'est
exactement le plan que j'imaginais tu
vas lui forcer F4 tu vas revenir tu vas
faire Dame des trois fousser 4 échanger
messieurs
non mais alors soit il s'en fiche soit
c'est juste pas les mêmes standards soit
il est même pas chez lui je sais pas en
fait il y a plein de raisons possibles
est-ce que je trouve pas mal en fait que
les gens jouent dans des clubs parce que
du coup tu dois avoir des gens autour de
toi que tu surveiller s'enlève la
suspicion
ça devrait être une obligation voilà il
est chez lui en est derrière on sait pas
en fait j'en sais rien
potentiellement ce qu'il a envie de
faire c'est échangeant c'est si c'est
faire ces quatre
[Musique]
du coup je me questionne
plusieurs options c'est soit tu fais ces
quatre tu vois un pion mais tu te
laisses pas murer et tu ressors ton faux
verset 5 et soit peut-être en faire ça
tu fais genre FO F6 je sais pas vous
prendre ces 6 puis on prend
et je sais pas quoi
j'aime pas trop mais c'est peut-être
très direct
je suis d'accord avec toi mais bon en
gros c'est ça la décision stratégique
des noirs
c'est ce que je veux bien prendre la
paire de fou on suit mal dans le fond à
long terme mais je vais faire G5 je vais
te fout de classe blanche j'attaque le
roi et pourquoi pas soit C4 c'est pour
pas laisser faire le plein d'heures donc
c'est un coup un peu profilactique et en
même temps on veut mettre le faux ça
dans ces 5 on se donne une case on
respire
complètement Fab c'est bien expliqué
mais en gros il faut faire quelque chose
on va pas juste se laisser
comme souvent avec toi c'est précis en
explication
et il a 8 minutes encore pour se décider
c'est dommage j'aurais bien voulu
voir un petit point R là tu vois pour
voir comment comment il prend sa
décision est-ce que il doit faire chaud
comme c'est visite donc il est quand
même à moins de riz un peu un peu en
jaune
couleur jaune alors que Magnus doit être
en couleur verte
comment tu fais pour prendre tes
décisions après
ça se discute quand même la dame c'est
possible mais je crois que la dame tu te
fais visser sur des seins à terre non
faire C4 même
ça pas traîné ramène le client C3
direction des 5
faut y aller
[Musique]
après bon une autre idée c'est juste
faire pousser trois dame B2 déjà
de qualité qui sera chiant ou il aime
bien
les pions
ouais ça donne un pion mais si ils font
[__] par exemple tu rechanges si tu
veux l'organisme
et après tu fais G5 et tu envoies il
regarde le fou B2 il est très moche et
l'option C4 il est pas enfin non plus
mais vite fait quoi
il a fait il a fait fouber 5 fois 6 ou
36 1.6 C4 d'AMC 7 ou C3 il enchaîne je
sais pas j'aime pas du tout ce que font
parce que
[Musique]
assez impliqué
mais il y a ici à mon avis va prendre
très très cher dans ce match on va voir
je pense qu'il aurait une nettement plus
de chance contre un joueur qui n'est pas
Carlson un camera je crois contre les
deux le problème et un moment ou un
autre tu vois probablement les jouets
tu as quand même un profil de joueur
comme ça qui réussissent jusqu'à un
certain niveau tu vois passer les étapes
et après un moment donné
en flèche quoi comme ça peut être comme
dans plein de fois enfin comme des gars
5 parties 5 défaites il a pas de bluff
que tu as les raisins il a juste tout
perdu
merci Ambroise
qui me fait un compliment sur le
répertoire de la Kalash sur cheesecom
la réponse dans une minute 30 mais belle
série de femmes sur les pions doublés
en espagnol aussi c'est vrai que ça
pourrait faire en anglais français
[Rires]
il faut que j'ai 6 donc dame 2 il défend
et là il est dans le mal avec les noirs
les plus importants de l'année que tu es
en train de suivre ici parce que c'est
les tournois il y a le plus de prix donc
c'est des tournois d'importance
exceptionnelle évidemment mais tu as des
joueurs qui ont peut-être plus de mal de
jouer de chez eux machin qui ont un peu
plus de mal à se concentrer et qui sont
peut-être qui vont peut-être plus
on va dire avoir comme objectif dans
leur saison les tournois qualificatifs
pour le cycle de championnats du monde
ouais éventuellement
après il y a aussi peut-être juste qu'il
est hors de forme
en juin juillet août après voilà en face
a bien joué aujourd'hui Sarana a bien
joué
le score est un peu sévère quoi on peut
sec non
tu dis ouais
mais donc oui bah mauvais mauvais
tournoi c'est que que un tournoi après
on verra s'il peut se ressaisir dans le
dans les prochaines séances
ok je vois ici
là il y a un très joli plan proposé par
l'ordi cavaliers H2 cavaliers G4
pour taper le fouet menacé tant des six
c'est pas difficile mais c'est très joli
j'ai pas trop de doute que ça doit
gagner assez tranquillou quoi ça
pourrait être notre partie d'analyse de
demain
ce stratégie c'est juste oui mais tu ne
sais pas jouer aux échecs
et maintenant que tu as fait acheter
5 j'ai plus rien à faire en H2 c'est ce
qu'on appelle un cours d'échec
il pourrait y avoir une facture qui part
pour égaliser à la fin de cette partie
si facilement
non mais j'aurais jamais fait j'aurais
fait dépenser j'aurais peut-être perdu
plus vite que lui ou plus mal mais
j'aurais jamais fait ça quoi mais ça se
trouve lui il va pas perdre enfin c'est
ça qui est mais je suis quand même assez
étonné
c'est pas le même
[Musique]
pourquoi tu
vraiment difficile à jouer
et au-delà de la pratique elle est juste
mauvaise la position parce qu'il y a
zéro plan il y a des faiblesses les
blancs petit à petit
et les blancs plein d'options ils
peuvent essayer de faire des ruptures à
la main si ils veulent avancer il peut
attaquer les pions ils peuvent
malheureusement
pour attaquer le roi maintenant qu'il y
a des trous partout tu fais rouges de
Tours géant enfin tu as des idées dans
tous les sens tu veux bien faire marcher
une
mais
essayer d'éviter les coups maintenant tu
te mets comme ça un peu en position
complexe
toi aussi bon oui passe son tour il va
faire des coups pour pas perdre direct
en fait ici mais rien de plus
H4 ok donc fixe se donne éventuellement
des cahiers G5 pour replacer le cahier
là-bas elle sera bien placé et non on
pas forcément envie de faire [__]
parce que ça a donné des fous de corps à
poser qui vont renforcé d'attaque il
vous C3 d'autant plus 5
peut-être qu'il sera obligé de le faire
un moment mais il a pas trop envie en
tout cas voilà
on s'en fiche enfin si il change ses
quatre il change T4 il fait B4 on
bougera le fou et alors
c'est incroyable c'est le récital
alors là il va se mettre en position de
fœtus
avec les Blancs c'est G3 et F4 plus tard
un jour pour
si tu trouves pas mieux un moment mais
encore ça pour aller taper vers gs7
il va faire
c'est étonnant comme plan mais c'est
joli
un peu court
ah c'est beau quand même
mais je suis sûr que l'ordi là tiens
oui
mais bon on est que des hommes
F3 pour un dame F2 aussi on va pouvoir
essayer de taper là en fin tu as rajouté
encore une cible
ouais
en tout cas mais donc F2 pourquoi pas
j'ai une idée c'est de faire F3 Tanger 6
pour D7
je pensais te reprendre j'ai 5 tours
on prend juste de 5 non
j'avais cette idée en tête dans F3
il fait dans alors j'ai vers H3 enfin en
tout cas avec les Blancs ça mange pas de
pain là il peut il peut tranquillement
tourner à droite à gauche
la position va pas radicalement changer
peut-être faire damage froid d'un F5
c'est pas des coups qui coûtent trop
cher pour l'instant
et c'est de forcer G6 revenir après
changer de plan c'était content d'avoir
forcer G6
et les cases noires il y a des problèmes
et puis deux minutes
à cette position
c'est car ou demi bah j'ai du mal à
comprendre moi-même c'est fin en fait si
tu peux l'appeler demi tu peux l'appeler
car en fait tu veux comme tu veux c'est
2000 dans le sens c'est demi-finale de
la winner mais c'est quart de finale
dans le sens où tu vas gagner 3 matchs
pour gagner le tournoi donc
c'est ni l'un ni l'autre en fait
un tiers
est-ce que ça marche mais c'est la
qualité en dessin
on verra ça se trouve ça tenir mais
après il faut dire que la position est
tellement dur
tellement difficile à jouer pour Wesley
pour ouais c'est vrai pour
essayer aussi d'ailleurs qui est
peut-être en train de tuer de son côté
c'est un récital c'est un récital
stratégique mais cette dame F3
maintenant elle a peut-être fait son job
c'est parti chemin et repartir vers B2
peut-être tout d'un coup
tu protèges C4 maintenant tu te
rediriges vers B2
et pour après on voyait un tour des 7
mais [__] un peu affaibli qu'il y a
plus de temps G6
ok merci
merci Fab on va voir si Magnus réussi à
conclure
il y a trois secondes d'incrément donc
il y a encore du temps côté
une minute ça lui suffit évidemment
enchaîner les coups mais la Magnus va
lui sortir une variante à mon avis
qui va lui faire très mal femme
qui passe
bref c'est un petit truc à prendre en
compte mais du coup j'ai 6 ça nous offre
ça on n'est pas particulièrement naze et
du coup je veux dire si on fait tourner
ça
semble logique de base peut-être qu'il y
a pris ce prix ce tour des 8
entre 8
peut-être à deux doigts
pas loin c'est normalement en fait tu
t'en fous c'est tu dis je suis
tranquille mais tu es pas tranquille
quoi
on va avoir un ce que ce que Magnus nous
prépare mais plus de 3 minutes il
réussit pas à terminer
mais c'est aussi la force de ces joueurs
comme Erika ici plus qu'on des gens de
notre calibre enfin si je peux mettre
dans le même calibre que toi mais c'est
qui réussit ça je veux beaucoup de coups
de merde mais jamais rien donné en un et
au bout d'un moment nous on finit
toujours par craquer
de pas gagner un truc qui doit gagner ça
doit gagner mais en fait te laisse rien
en un et là ma nièce fait froid et
peut-être qu'il veut du damas 3 alors il
fait tour des 6
IDE est plus faible
contrairement c'est 5 à 6
j'imagine la meilleure chance c'est de
faire tourner autour B7 je sais pas
laquelle des deux
enfin
et dans l'autre cas tu perds 5 et tu te
refais ma télé
du coup c'est chiant
pour fouder 8 x 6 c'était peut-être très
bien joué gabeux mais ça on n'avait pas
du tout et là les finales de foot
couleur opposées sont perdus parce que
si on échange toutes les tours il y a
[__] un F4 ou des 6 faut prendre parce
que nous on passe on n'est pas à l'autre
il est bloqué par nos pions c'est pour
ça qu'il va échanger
et il va faire tourner 5 collecter
collecter
sinon de toute façon
[Musique]
tu dois avoir mieux que ça
juste fou ces trois et il y a pas ton
problème
il faut juste beaucoup mieux aux échecs
[Musique]
il veut te reprendre B3 mais je pense
que faire pion prend H5 tu reprends C3
H6 déjà c'est marrant
mais
j'ai acheté intermédiaire c'est marrant
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il va faire à mon
avis il va faire si on prend H5
juste parce que c'est drôle entre les
ça ça fait Punto monsieur très très
jolie partie de Magnus on va tout de
suite
[Musique]
et c'est pas clair ils ont pas trop de
temps
qui semble emballer et en balance ça
peut tourner vers une nulle peut-être je
sais pas ça dépend à 4 s'il disparaît ou
pas le truc c'est qu'il y avait tout
reprend à 4 ou que d'avant mais il est
tout reprend F2 pour devient la dame
alors attention il y a pas d'âme 3 à 3
parce qu'il y a de nouveau
[Musique]
tu le vire comment la tête tu mets une
tour
[Musique]
repartir avec la tourelle Thomas Tourrel
qui repars
pour gagner hein mais bon
après c'est que dès que tu vas te barrer
tes pièces il va venir en BOA avec sa
tour
alors
[Rires]
ça fait nul et ben écoutez les amis
merci d'avoir suivi cette première
partie on va repartir
[Musique]
on est de retour Fab
et alors attends pourquoi est-ce qu'il y
a un coup de jouer ici un coup c'est un
Quick
bravo de laisser Hikaru
mais
Eric Guy on va se mettre côté Magnus en
fait
puisque là en fait Carlson il va avoir
les Noirs mais attends
on a été décalé ils ont changé
et ça sort les caméras et donc Magnus
qui a des Noirs les noirs et on va
afficher les scores 1 0 1 0 pour Magnus
donc
avec A6 B5 pour s'accrocher au pion
alors ça peut être un truc pour faire
nul là c'est bien quoi
parce que en gros les blancs ils vont te
faire à 4 B3
tu vas enlever tous les pions
il va te rester que c'est 7 tu vas faire
mettre en C5 tu vas enlever contre des
quatre et tu auras quatre contre quatre
allez droit c'est ça le but des Noirs
c'est bien quoi salut à Théodore dans le
chat qui nous salue Fabien
tu nous entendras avec un petit décalage
parce qu'on a une minute trente de
décalage par rapport à toi
ne pense pas qu'on a pas voulu te
répondre rapidement c'est juste qu'on en
a pas la possibilité
qui s'alimente un petit peu
il a bien raison
il faut manger un Fabien pendant les
parties je le fais pas ça que je suis
pas si fort que ça
tu manges pas beaucoup pendant les
parties
encore une chance de oui alors
parce qu'il a déjà perdu deux fois
c'est un peu le scénario que tu nous pré
disait pour cette partie alors c'est bon
si il fait à prendre ou pas
mais en gros si tu fais baisser baisser
4 bon je sais pas si c'est 5 déjà ou pas
en gros on va essayer d'obtenir
un truc très égal et très anulant
alors qu'il y a quand même une petite
amélioration par rapport au global chat
Championship c'est qu'on attend plus la
fin de l'heure totale pour enchaîner les
parties oui les enchaîne assez bien oui
oui bon après ils font comme ils veulent
ça freine pause plus grande mais non
mais ça je trouve que c'est quand même
hein
il y avait autant de pause que de
Fabien essaie de s'alimenter en eau
voilà hydrater
en nourriture
grâce à hersing ouais important permet
de mieux respirer
découvrir ce que contient que vous
respirez et prenez le contrôle de la
qualité de votre air intérieur
exactement taux d'humidité température
température
les particules
etc donc
le chauffage tout le monde
un petit brumisateur qui peut si jamais
c'est trop sec
brumidifier
donc je m'attends assez 5 quand même
peut-être retarder d'abord de tout chaud
et fuite mais
j'adore je suis très heureux j'ai juste
un commentaire Youtube qui me dit
quelqu'un qui vient vous avez dit la
mauvaise canon c'est 15 + 3 c'est 10 + 5
ils ont 15 ils ont 15 ans
juste ça me fait rire donc non c'est
bien 15 + 3 j'en profite pour rappeler
la cadence je pense on dit la bonne au
cas où désolé mais c'est écrit qu'en
fait très étonnant sinon quoi non non
c'est sûr mais j'en profite du coup pour
appeler la cadence ça me fait tu sais
une petite transition cadence
Ambroise dit pourtant c'est vraiment
être mieux probablement alors pas
vraiment non ça va très bien pour les
noirs
le truc c'est que personnellement quand
je donne des cours des joueurs plus plus
amateurs je le recommande pas vraiment
parce qu'en fait finalement c'est ce que
veulent les blancs c'est donner spion
temporairement d'ailleurs pour prendre
le centre et c'est pas évident de lutter
avec les Noirs si tu connais pas
exactement ce que tu dois faire mais en
fait bon bah ils savent très bien ce
qu'ils font ces raisons bien analysé
avec l'ordinateur puis même son
ordinateur je verrai que les livres et
la connaissance et donc ils savent quand
même quand les blancs normalement on le
cou le plus critique c'est de jouer E4
quand vous avez français 4 ils prennent
tout le centre et ils savent pas me
jouer du coup E5 qui est pas trop
intuitif vous avez plutôt faire des
coups comme eux si ce machin vous
rabourir l'impression d'être très mal et
donc tant qu'à faire on dit bah défendez
le pion des cinq faites la slave faites
le grand bidame classique etc etc mais
en soit c'est pas objectivement meilleur
que de prononcer 4
mais vous allez le faire
mais c'est pas meilleur non
voilà c'est pas du tout un mauvais
Gambie accepté
donc là Magnus qui laisse le pion à 6 en
prise
mais j'imagine qu'il veut reprendre
échanger faire Damas 8 pour aller
attaquer le pion A4 après petit à petit
en gros il sait ce qu'il fait quoi ce
qui va jouer très vite
et on risque de voir ce scénario dans la
partie
très dominant car
dans ce match
le but au blanc non c'est peut-être
enfin vlades de musique il y a deux
trois ans que c'était même la manière la
plus facile d'égaliser au noir mais avec
l'analyse pas juste bien sûr il y a
quand même il faut un peu connaître
quand même
d'ailleurs Maxime s'est mis à jour
mais après c'est pas forcément c'est
peut-être plus forcément le cas
et après c'est pas très fun c'est
souvent un truc pour vraiment tu vois
avec les Noirs tu prétends pas que tu
veux gagner tu sais faire nul quoi mais
bon normalement avec les Noirs c'est un
bon résultat
non tu prétends rien du tout non
tu fais ce que tu peux
non non
mais comme je vous dis pas au début
pour bien connaître quoi
changer en fait il va être trop dur à
défendre ce pion en quatre évidemment si
les blancs
ça va être sympa
c'est 5 sûrement pour un autre cavalier
et ça met trop de pièces quoi
mais j'imagine du Carlson connaît parce
qu'en fait la décision est pas enfin
j'ai déjà vu plusieurs fois genre truc
mais elle est pas simple à prendre
c'était pas sur le bouffer le pire parce
que sinon
pour venir s'activer et les pièces
blanches sont trop mal placées
en plus dans mon C4 du coup elle est
vulnérables
alors là pour l'instant bon c'est pas
trop le moment parce qu'on perdait 7
mais donc
c'est 5 c'est le coup que tu as envie de
regarder mais bon après peut-être même
tour C8 un coup moche a priori
mais
sur rocade pareil
mais disons c'est moins enfin faut
calculer plus
et ça c'est quelque chose que tu n'aimes
pas trop faire Fab non c'est ça
aucun problème contre contre
le droit à un Magnus des grands jours
enfin ça impérial pour l'instant
très facile
pas avec les Blancs
B3 qui paye pas de mine mais
stratégiquement il a complètement dominé
et là il est noir aucune
aucune souffrance de rien quoi c'est
trop facile
moi j'avais pas trop de doute quand j'ai
vu la fiche du match
[Musique]
mais c'est toujours beau de voir
après c'est peut-être un joli coup quand
même
c'est compliqué pour
irigaliser
qui tombe sur nettement plus fort que
lui
je pense que j'aurais eu nettement plus
de chance contre un autre joueur
il a plus de chance
d'accord
c'est comme la pétrole chiant mais
égalisant non j'aurais pas dit ça
je sais pas
de toute façon elle va être niveau il y
a rien qui c'est pas comme on dit en
fait pas trop se comparer avec le haut
niveau
tellement différent comme genre sur tu
aimerais mieux avoir des gants bien
miroirs des trucs bizarres mais en fait
tu peux plus non
c'est pas trop possible
il doit être sérieux il joue pas pour
faire le spectacle il joue pour la
procédé pour gagner et puis de temps en
temps tu as quand même de belles parties
mais ils sont pragmatique essaie de
jouer le voilà donc
basiquement voilà tu as les Noirs nuls
c'est un bon résultat de ma caméra parce
que il fait un nombre de grimaces
et juste
ok c'est juste nul ok j'ai compris
je vais voir s'il était perdant ou juste
il y avait rien obtenu au Blanco et et
ça le saoule
en gros il a juste un obtenu au Blanco
il va se faire nullifier la tronchasse
tranquille donc pour revenir ici bon il
faut trouver un moyen de vraiment
d'aller bouffer sur un 4 juste
donc
s'accrocher petit à petit
c'est dur
c'est dur femme
torse 8
alors attention c'est toujours enfin
c'est proche des gars les Magnus va
probablement récupérer le pion mais il
est quand même du bon côté irigalis oui
oui il est pas il a quand même réussi à
mettre
quand même
une petite pression
pour l'instant il a joué son ouverture
Magnus lui a donné le pion il l'a pris
et puis bon bah soit il le perd il fait
nul soit il le garde et il presse quoi
pour l'instant il a plus de coup
difficile à jouer
ok non
pour le moment ça va
mais je suis sûr ça existe enfin il est
rentré trop facilement dans la variante
donc
on a peut-être été trop
trop optimiste
donc moi je
du coup Magnus un peu réfléchir bon que
ça physiquement mais bon ils ont fait
nul le parti je pense l'autre partie ils
ont fait nul donc on a finalement choisi
le bon match on nous parlait IKA
Rousseau machin la première partie était
peut-être emballé mais on a eu un ami
victoire en attendant il a la deuxième
ils ont déjà fait nul
on est du bon côté du live
[Musique]
il a l'air de laisser non
il a l'air de laisser cavalier prend
aussi puis on prend le 6 d'un proche
il a trop voulu j'imagine
et solidification des blancs
mais bon aussi c'est un peu chiant quoi
il doit pas être bien
soit toujours et après de contrôle de
l'autre côté mais c'est plus si simple
mais il a bien joué avec le damas 2 a
été vraiment fort
s admettons
[Musique]
avant je veux dire
ouais
mais ok c'est pour empêcher 3 ouais mais
c'est pas simple en fait c'est très bien
joué de la part de ici mais bon
a priori oui mais
je sais pas
ce qu'il a raté en fait si on prend d'un
point c'est quand même
il nous a pas habitué à rater des trucs
facile c'est jamais facile mais là quand
même
bon à moins qu'il y a un truc qui
défendent pour le noir mais
ce que ça suit une partie gagner au
blanc par Axel de l'Orne
c'est quand même un énorme raté parce
que ça avait pas l'air d'être très con
enfin pas très compliqué pour leur
niveau mais tu le regardes après du coup
je sais pas ce qui te plaît pas c'est
dur de pas ils sont
il continue à avoir une position
pressante
tant que là ouais le jour il y a plus
qu'à 4 on en parle plus
sans légère souffrance
quand même de son côté elle est déjà
perdu contre saut global chez Champions
il est en train de refaire la même chose
tu as pas envie d'aller en loser au cul
en fait
j'ai pas quand il fait il a le talent de
la nuit
qui veut quoi
mais c'est bête d'être comme ça tu as
l'impression que si vous voulez jouer
pour gagner il serait vraiment
qu'il préfère peut-être faire nuit
j'ai essayé de gagner parfois il s'en
fout en fait de gagner je pense c'est un
juste pas
bah là il a fait sa journée c'est bon
quoi maintenant je peux faire mes
petites nulles tout va bien quoi
le truc hallucinant sans plus
connaissant le Wesley c'est qui a quand
il joue contre
là il joue quoi
alors que nul il était qualifié le
contexte c'est que c'était la quatrième
partie il menait une victoire à zéro et
il a en fait ma médaille de moins quoi
donc
[Musique]
mais je vois pas comment il le fait
disparaître en fait donc c'est très
chiant pour les noirs
tout à l'heure
moi non plus tu as quand même un pion
moins et tu suis plus 4 minutes mais je
pense pas qu'il soit content d'ailleurs
ça peut en mettre un peu de piment dans
ce match enfin c'était parti pour être
expédié la première partie
démonstration on va dire deuxième savoir
peut-être pour une lune sans histoire tu
dis bon bah
il va te boucler le match à la prochaine
et là
propose dans le chat damasin qui ici qui
est surpuis on prend dame en maths
devrait s'en rendre compte petit manque
de discretion mais jolie
F3 cavalier
le car il va venir en C3 maintenant
clairement les mens sont mieux enfin je
sais pas à quel point c'est beaucoup
mieux ou juste mieux
[Musique]
on a parlé espion quoi
l'objectif non atteint
j'ai une autre question niveau
organisation est-ce que Naka esto doit
attendre je crois ouais je crois que ça
repart tous ensemble alors est-ce que
tous ensemble ou pas mais je pense
qu'ils doivent au moins attendre la fin
de cette partie de façon on fera une
petite pause quand même parce que le
tout c'est à dire 6h donc on peut pas y
arriver
sans se poser à certains moments
pas ce genre dommage en gratter des
parties des coups évidemment vu le
spectacle offert on aimerait bien
pouvoir absolument ne rien rater
ça c'est sûr
ce serait tellement dommage
sur le title Baba qui va me va me
confirmer il va m'écrire dans la soirée
vers 22 23h pour me dire
mais il est pas contre l'idée il est pas
contre l'idée
même pas du tout contre l'idée mais bon
après c'est tard donc ça dépend
l'énergie terrestre qui lui restera
connaissant le 13
partez du principe qu'il est chaud
il y a toujours d'énergie terrestre
normalement
c'est sûr mais bon 23h c'est tard quand
même
ouais
5 qui bloque le pion attaque le cahier 3
et tout protéger
ça semble ça semble cool logique enfin
tout
des fantômes place la dame recentralise
la dame quelque part
je sais pas si regarde d'autres en fait
ça paraît tellement
je vois pas trop de suite en fait
j'étais en une je sais pas moi je vois
pas bon
je vais pas mettre un peu de pression
sur cette pendule là on voit qu'il reste
plus que 3 minutes de à Magnus et on
aurait envie d'aller chercher un petit
coup de un petit coup de poussette
pendulesque
alors qu'est-ce qui peut nous arriver
bon peut-être peut-être le fameux cahier
des signes
du coup faut défendre ce cavalier avec
de j'imagine
parce que
[Musique]
tu vas pas le récupérer j'ai pas le
temps j'arrive pas
du coup qu'est-ce qui le gène là dedans
on sait pas
il passe beaucoup de temps il plombe
beaucoup après bon ça va enfin je veux
dire il a quand même du temps il va son
corps donc le temps investi déjà ça te
faire deux deux trois minutes qui
réfléchit
[Musique]
après tu as plein de ventes complexes
avec des cavaliers C6 Internet
aussi possible
mais bon il y a des vents un peu
complexes
nous parle de cavalier prend un 4 aussi
ici mais qui prend un 4 j'ai pas
cavalier prendre dame et dame
je pense
dont on parlait
[Musique]
c'est notre histoire dommage je veux pas
avoir réussi là pour égaliser un tout
petit peu accéléré après c'est très
facile à dire
mais tu vois il aurait
coûts
[Musique]
c'est toujours facile à posteriori de se
dire ah oui bon il y avait pas mieux
mais alors que mais c'est dommage il
aurait pu réussir à faire une
accélérateur là je sais pas par contre
le truc c'est que là c'est pas loin de
réfléchir il y a une mauvaise gestion de
temps parce que il a réfléchi avant il y
a pas de souci
c'est pas un coup dur on découvre des
deux ça fait un mauvais
parce qu'ils doivent vouloir sur
cavalier français 3 cavaliers ici ah non
en fait il a bien joué on dit de la
merde il a bien joué et dame prend un 4
qui prend le sept roi et F8 il adore
tu te casses et bon déjà dernièrement
après faut voir mais bon tu aurais dame
français 5 donc en réalité c'est non on
est mauvaise langue en fait il a vu un
truc très fort on a complètement raté
et il a très très bien navigué dans le
dans la tactique mais heureusement qu'il
a le foudé de 1 parce que s'il avait
joué le cavalier de qui était le coup
entre guillemets facile qui est pas
trouvé
5 minutes pour rien et là c'est le
contraire il m'a un énorme coup de
pression sur Magnus
bah c'est
bonne nouvelle pour le blanc
et puis regarde le temps sur pareil plus
qu'une 20 au bout d'un moment même si
les trois secondes parcours il faut
prendre une décision
il est proche de l'égalisation là quand
même
Erika ici
le temps qui s'égraine plus qu'une 10 en
nous l'ordi il est très heureux de ma
vie mais je n'en suis pas faire juste
qu'il y ait des deux à ce moment-là
donc
c'est extrêmement dur on peut l'avoir
potentiellement enfin
si on trouve un coup qui on veut
défendre des seins qui lutte contre qui
est ici pourquoi pas mais en tout cas
c'est difficile il leur explique 40
secondes au champion du monde plus de 37
plus de 35
fois un coup de l'ordi et qui doit être
très mauvais mais je veux dire c'est
aussi logique que dans ma vitre mais il
faut éviter
c'est encore plus logique en fait
mais ça va perdre sur le chant c'est une
merde qui a eu 4 une découverte un truc
plus que 20 secondes plus que 17 enfin
avec les trois secondes quand il va
jouer
ça tombe sous les 10 secondes Fab
et il a le damas 8
ouais c'est fort quand même côté magnech
il doit pas être bien il y a ici il doit
pas être bien
et ouais parce que lui sort le seul coup
de la Manche
mais bon
si tu maintiens une certaine pression
dans la position c'est pas si facile
mais bon là ça disparaît direct c'est
trop symétrique il y a plus d'un B5
la menace en gros maintenant on voulait
faire quelque chose
on a deux manières on préfère aussi
d'ailleurs
ce qu'on peut tenter un A5 et des dames
prend à 5 tu prends des cinq
[Musique]
déjà
OK
c'est pas de bol
donc il y a pas à 5 qui aurait pu être
une option
bon mais au moins ça peut lui donner un
peu de baume au coeur pour la suite du
match il aura obtenu quelque chose
parce que tu peux avoir envie de mettre
un peu trop là
j'imagine mal qu'on
met trop
tu peux
mais très gros joueur un Magnus
ce que tu vois il a plus qu'une 20 et là
nous on le sait de par l'ordi mais il
est en train de se taper la tête contre
un mur
tu vas te dire que tu as quelque chose
là quand même tu as joué beaucoup de
bons coups avec les Blancs et
visuellement ça doit passer
et tu peux te faire contrer parce que tu
veux tenter
5 puis on prend des cinq fous prend à 5
on prend ces quatre et se dire allez
tiens il est faible et là tu peux
peut-être finir par la perdre en faisant
le con comme ça en fait
mais ça peut ça peut encore exploser
côté Haroun plus de 35 secondes ouais tu
vois tu peux en fait là quand tu as plus
de temps comme ça après 10 secondes
chacun il fait à 55
6 aussi il y a demain maintenant c'est
la différence comme il y a plus le pion
à 4 il y a échec mais bon gère ça
continue c'est que le début je vais
essayer de récupérer des seins tu peux
la perdre en réalité avec les blancs
mais tu peux la gagner aussi là tout
peut t'arriver maintenant je vais
prendre
nous parler pour essayer de jouer le
gain mais attention
je pense que c'est juste que tu
t'imposes un petit peu en fait non mais
là tu es plus mieux oui je sais mais là
tout peut t'arriver en fait donc
c'est peut-être même plus facile à jouer
au noir bizarrement tu as du caca qui
arrive en Détroit
ce qui va faire G6 je pense pas
sinon
j'avais peur peut-être qu'il y a un truc
avec du cahier des 6 mais apparemment
non du coup
normalement nul c'est bon contre 3 voilà
c'est on est dans l'irrationnel Fabien
on en rentre dans l'irrationnel si j'ai
6 peut-être un moment ouais
plus beaucoup de temps qui est des
quatre va être joué ce qui va caler
fuber 4 non il échange en fait alors qui
joue pour nul les deux apparemment
tension à même c'est final la femme
ça échange les dames ou quoi il peut
encore y avoir matière à faire de la
connerie normalement c'est complètement
nul les dames en plus donnant
des possibilités de perpétuel
mais il peut s'énerver avec les Blancs
et il s'énerve
mais tu as envie de t'énerver en fait
et moi ça me rend fou quand j'étais
gagnant comme ça j'ai parfois j'ai du
mal mais en fait
il va pas tenter le diable
belle
passe d'armes entre les deux hommes
et match nul ok très bien petit
déception évidemment
mais qui a quand même eu la lucidité de
prendre la nul on va repasser dans le
match donc petite pause et petite pause
pour pour la troisième partie la
troisième ronde car ou demi-finale
mettre attends on peut mettre l'escort à
jour avant de repartir au moins c'est
fait on va aller voir qui partent
et donc on repart on revient dans une
dizaine de minutes à tout de suite les
amis à toute
[Musique]
les amis nous sommes de retour
en fait
ah mais c'est pour ça en fait c'est
ouais en fait à chaque fois ouais ok
ouais c'est revient tout le temps en
retard il nous met il nous met dans le
mal donc faut remettre la bonne caméra
de Magnus alors ça c'est pas le plus dur
en réalité mais mais on se fait on se
fait complètement piéger par le Slug qui
n'est pas à l'heure qui est devant la
cam on dit ok quand ils arrivent le
quatrième mais voici ils sont fous
complètement
il vient en retard
et ça lui récit plutôt bien voilà
donc vous avez vu Wesley arrivée
mais il repart
on va mettre
par ici
mais du coup vous avez compris
son petit manège
le manège de Wesley ouais
qui va peut-être faire une île très très
rapide on peut aller voir on peut
laisser cette caméra
et en fait et en fait juste voir s'ils
font une ultra rapide ce qu'il est
capable ouais c'est ah mais il joue pas
encore en fait
on n'a pas on n'a pas les rêves donc là
c'était un gambidame au final Fab et
même une slave triangle ouais à mon
époque le E4 ici était très populaire
moi
était extrêmement populaire
mais c'était hyper chaud
mais il est 15h sont un peu défoncé
mais c'est toujours jouable bon a priori
ça doit juste il y a des enfants pour
les Noirs s'ils font plus et
là en fait c'est plutôt tombé dans une
[Musique]
gambidas plus classique
un excellent joueur de carsbad
globalement en ce moment il joue avec
mais je joue pas contre
s'il gagne il est déjà qualifié
il a une première balle de match en
réalité oui il est qualifié si il fait
nul il faudra alors
qui ne perd pas la dernière
ou alors il devra passer par le
Armageddon
il devra il devra passer par la case à
auquel cas
ce qu'ils ont commencé wesler ils ont
commencé tu les as et ça fait pas la
petite
je pense qu'ils ont ils doivent jamais
l'ouverture que la première c'est la
tour aussi qui peut
on aurait pu connaissant imaginer
berlinoise
nul direct et Magnus qui laisse le fond
à F4 je pense il veut prendre l'autre
qui va prendre un F5 ouais probablement
ok donc il veut il veut il veut
recommencer avec des fous de colorés
mais
donc on va voir ce qui nous fait dans
celle-là
je sais pas
il met un mur
peut avoir du mal à revenir il est plus
très agile mais non mais H4 qui est F4
pour le coup mais c'est
pour ça que ça me surpris parce que
c'est un petit appareil cheveux mettre
le fond G2 je sais pas normalement on ne
met pas qu'on comme ça pas sur la bonne
diagonale
c'est étonnant
on va voir comment il décide de
continuer
les trois plus logique
je crois que c'est juste sur G6 il veut
se faire caler H4 drama qui est en G3 on
a trouvé très dominé il veut se faire ce
tour de carrosserie à un moment soit
viager de Fiat soit par F3 retour 5
et du coup il peut passer par H4 parce
que la case maintenant il protéger par
le pion
après je veux dire un petit juste aussi
jouer des coups pas trop prendre de
risques et puis voir et puis la sonde
nulle le dérange pas spécialement il
fait nul dans la dernière il sera
qualifié
on voit qu'il s'alimente
moi j'ai des graines ou des noix ou
qui mange des petites bouchées quoi il
prend pas tu sens que c'est pas un
hamburger quoi
ça doit être des petites bouchées
et donc les perdants de de ce match là
joueront contre les gagnants de la
looser cue voilà donc est-ce qu'on sait
déjà
contre Sarana
et donc mais c'est pas bizarre ça moi je
le croiserai en fait en gros si garde
cette paire
il rejoint Sarana déjà mais je crois que
tu croises
pas
c'est bizarre ou c'est normal
mais en gros je préfère ne pas avoir
tout le temps le même match et au cas où
il se retrouve à la fin des fins parce
que c'est comme ça il faut voir
peut-être ils ont décidé de croiser ici
tu sais
je veux dire tu vois dans plein de
peut-être là je sais pas comment c'est
tu peux le faire dans les deux sens en
fait ça c'est une question de choix
on est revenu à F3
particulièrement en fait c'était juste
peut jouer avec grand rock ça me
rappelle une vieille partie d'overboard
c'est souvent risqué surtout quand c'est
5 mais bon
il va le faire je pense
parce que même si de faire petit rock
c'est pas grave ouais
ici il fait pas petit rock c'est cool de
l'avoir déjà de ça donc
pour le moment il a pas grand chose
voilà
une position qui joue il joue il y a pas
de risques et puis c'est ça structure
dans les dans les Carlsbad
bon je sais pas sur le plan a priori
c'est la taille minoritorité bon il y a
plus alors ça c'est la nouvelle manière
de jouer
c'est comme ça il y a 30 ans
il t'aurait dit ça non à l'époque
faire baisser quand il y a du BK
donc ça voudrait dire qu'on aurait
peut-être
une logique je sais pas je ferai
vraiment ça moi mais ça fait pas c'est
pas deux fois le même match en deux
jours quoi
potentiellement
est-ce qu'on fait des paris sur les
matchs non il y a pas de en France c'est
pas c'est pas possible de le faire
à titre personnel je m'amuserai pas à
faire des paris sur
une partie qui sont jouées sur Internet
oui mais en général les échecs c'est un
peu trop facile c'est trop facile
ouais ou même enfin tu sais que j'ai eu
aussi parce que j'habite en Russie avait
il y a des bookmakers du coup qui
faisaient les échecs ils avaient arrêté
parce qu'il y avait trop de parties
trucs
limité vraiment les sommes à des toutes
petites sommes
peut-être le kopeck
trop de problèmes de trucage non mais
disons ok mais dans un truc comme le
tennis ou pas si facile
que tu proposes nul quand tu as envie
déjà rien que quoi
vraiment voir si le mec a soufflé
aucune balle tu te prends des 06
n'importe quand enfin ça devient vite
visible quoi bon après ça à faire je
pense non mais oui
de toute façon en France je crois que
les chèques c'est pas dans l'agrément
Argel
donc je crois pas que les sites
proposent à moins que
moi
je ne parle pas
qui peut être un plan
et c'est ça maintenant c'est c'est cars
va dans les joues un peu non
et finalement c'est logique je pense pas
majorité
oui mais
pendant longtemps on a considéré que la
taille de minorité est très très forte
et c'était dur à contrer maintenant
que toi tu bouges
et donc les deux joueurs jouent dans
leur majorité
juste tu nous fais un petit point
que je veux dire c'est Alpha qui a
commencé à jouer comme ça ou c'est je
sais pas qui qui est venu avec
les B5 et compagnie et puis bon
moi j'ai l'impression que c'est depuis
alpha zéro que ça joue autant comme ça
je sais parce qu'il y a une partie
ça peut être déjà eu lieu mais j'avais
l'impression que c'était très mineur en
fait
est-ce qu'on verra mvl bientôt alors ml
on le verra peut-être en prochain slic
s'il veut jouer qui démarre quand on
doit démarrer pour nous le 16 février
normalement mais
j'ai pas l'horaire j'ai rien je sais pas
combien
ça va commencer en imagine
elle sera le 16 hein
ce qu'on a pas bien
en fait c'est fort autour
il y a beaucoup de d'équipes à
puissantes est-ce que il y a une équipe
arménienne non mais il y a beaucoup
d'équipes fortes
les équipes indiennes il y en a deux
trois qui sont notamment très très
costauds
qui est hyper forte
c'est beau quand ils ont Hikaru alors
leur
bornique
[Musique]
son frère forcément ils ont à peu près
le même niveau en réalité et Jennifer en
fait c'est une équipe qui est quasiment
imbattable je pense un fait de CF
bornique après
[Musique]
parce que il y a un Capello ça et 25 50
Jennifer des États-Unis au féminin enfin
c'est je pense qu'il va tout le monde en
fait à moins qu'on les joue en réel
en playoff finale on a l'impression
ouais on fait une Alfort roulant on
pourrait mettre la pression et peut-être
faire un peu craquer leur milieu de
terrain mais physiquement derrière
mais je pense que sinon ils sont juste
imbattable en fait
après j'étais un peu ouais de des choix
de
ils ont l'air fort
et nous ça pourrait être quoi nous si on
est vraiment max ce serait Sacha mvl
Katia Maëlle
mais bon on a pas de très grosse
spécialiste Internet
malheureusement on a décidé de pas en
prendre on aurait peut-être dû se
tourner sur des tu as peut-être du
jospel on aurait pu prendre tête duandry
spécialistes spécialiste cette martyr
aussi
qu'on prenne les prochaines là on a pris
des gens qu'on aime bien l'IRL machin et
tout faire une équipe mais il faut
peut-être vraiment se tourner vers des
spécialistes
du jeu Internet
donc il a joué BK
tu te remets un pion en F4
quand même
tu crois vraiment que je me suis fait
mater plein de fois en faisant des
conneries comme ça
parce que vu de loin
qu'il y a des sacrifices de partout qui
marche tout le temps mais
il y a les raisins jouer avec nous non à
lire et je joue pas avec nous fait-on
une équipe sans budget est-ce qu'il joue
tout court
je crois pas non je crois qu'il y a pas
d'équipe qui ont les budgets pour le
pour le faire jouer
parce que Magnus je sais qui joue avec
les chaises bras ouais mais bon
peut-être par amitié aussi avec Eric
qui sont assez amis Magnus et Eric
Hansen un peu comme nous mvl tu vois
amitié donc tu as quelques gars qui
jouent pour pour s'amuser pour un peu
clic quand ils sont dispo quand machin
après je crois qu'il y a so et
caroanna avec avec
systématiquement payé par cette dur pour
le mec t'envoie des centaines de
milliers voire des millions d'euros sur
plusieurs années
je peux faire hein
par match aussi tu vois mais au passage
prends un chèque tu vois dans ta gueule
mais
oui 450
comme ça
donc
tu as cette équipe là mais en fait tu
peux trouver en fait je peux dire là je
suis en train de te parler mais c'est
vrai que ça peut intéresser les gens
c'est un autre événement de chasse.com
donc c'est un rapport avec son entrain
de regarder c'est intéressant ça
commence la semaine prochaine pour moi
c'est la plus belle compétition
organisée par chaise comme sur l'année
en tout cas je trouve il y a combien
d'équipe 16
format c'est deux poules 4 poules alors
il y a pas de poule il faut gagner 5
matchs c'est un système suisse en fait
25/7
pour Descartes et après si tu gagnes le
quart de finale
qui se passera aux USA en Europe
alors on a notre apparition du premier
match au bon on va se faire
oncer et derrière on joue à 16h30 au
lieu des 19h que j'avais demandé donc
c'est pas de bol
et on joue contre les Indiens voilà
aucune chance
même pas la peine d'y aller
on va se faire dézinguer
alors je te dire l'équipe contre qui on
joue ils ont Erika ici
et des gars que je connais pas
la peine de jouer peut-être et
potentiellement très fort
et alors c'est qui notre seconde joueuse
par rapport à Rica elle est quand même
en dessous quoi
du premier truc je sais pas pourquoi on
tombe sur une équipe aussi forte
d'entrée
mais c'est clairement pas de bol
de Grand Prix un candidat elle a un truc
ouais je sais pas lequel
on va se faire défoncer d'entrée mais
pourquoi on joue contre des joueurs
aussi fort
j'avais dit qu'on voulait jouer à 19h
nous 16h30 ça nous fait chier quoi
je sais pas je peux pas te répondre
les Indiens ouais les Indiens et les
Chinois et après on aurait pu jouer les
Chinois en fait on va se faire défoncer
un match qu'on peut gagner en fait c'est
ça
j'entends parler de l'équipe d'Ico les
Saint-Louis
c'est pas vraiment un gros mais
on va changer on doit croiser des
horaires je sais pas on n'a pas des
Australiens des mecs un peu cool là qui
sont accessibles non mais si on a du
pôle on jouerait contre Berlin prochain
match ils vont contre l'équipe du
carreaux donc ils vont se faire défoncer
ou les crottes
mais c'est les seuls que tu peux battre
en fait
il faudra avoir de la chance de foi et
faire un exploit une fois c'est ça
le maintien mais on joue vraiment le
maintien
un match sur trois je sais plus
bon je vous
mais là on a pas de bol en fait on tombe
enfin on tombe contre les pires non
parce qu'on aurait pu tomber sur
l'équipe avec Fabiano non il y a pas de
souci Fabiano Dominguez Chiang Bock
enfin bon n'importe quoi en fait
ils ont des joueuses aussi de notre pâte
est mauvaise quoi
on va se faire défoncer en fait
on a aucune chance
mais bon c'était pas mieux si on est
jolie chinois oui
[Musique]
bon ça fait défoncer aussi
normalement à moins qu'on soit à zéro
sur deux
par avion
mais il est 300050 sur Internet
en fait tu te fais écraser par toutes
les équipes
regarde les autres indiens vite
tu as jamais aucune chance
Ikaru le coup en Guyane fait de CIF
[Musique]
on avait une belle équipe toi tu crois
mais je pense que gagner un match ce
serait beau déjà
après c'est qu'on a aucun spécialiste
internet donc forcément
bon après si on agit
qui se fait défoncer par les
spécialistes là
Berlin Colars
il y a un monde où ça va
nous a pas déçus on vous parlez un petit
peu de projets
c'est une autre compétition qui aura
lieu par équipe
ça nous a une petite transition une
petite coupure mais bon c'est aussi
intéressant parce que c'est
c'est toute compétition
les playoffs ça me paraît vraiment
impossible
bon pour revenir à cette partie alors un
de Magnus mais qui fait son plan et
c'est détruire le rock adverse donc
il a échangé un de ses pions f.w quand
l'option h ou maintenant et on a trois
contre deux il va encore envoyer un pion
h pour démolir un autre pion et c'est
essayer de s'ouvrir un peu des lignes
pour s'en fout des trois pour la tour
qui ira vers H1 etc quand même
ça
ouais Maxime
pour la Projec mais on manque de d'un
gros spécialiste internet quoi
tiens Maxime qui est dans le chat il va
pas être confiant quand tu entends le
discours du coach mais non mais en plus
c'est un coup de bambou que Katia puisse
pas jouer le premier match parce qu'en
fait elle est hyper important dans notre
équipe
parce que du coup
là au milieu si tout le monde peut jouer
parce que quand même
ça fait toujours 23,50
même si elle a plus je veux dire
on a une chance
mais harika ouais après
sur un clic bah faut pas qu'elle fasse
deux quoi
va peut-être enfin
oui mais du coup si elle fait deux
points
après tu me diras mvl mvl et Richard
aussi quoi
après ils sont peut-être pas dispo
oui
on sait pas on verra
ça se trouve avec toi
tu seras là
mais c'est vrai que tu as dans l'équipe
tout d'un coup ouais
50 c'était dans la moyenne et l'eau
évidemment mais en fait l'équipe type
elle est vraiment forte mais on pourra
peut-être pas autant la lignée qu'on ne
le souhaite
après ça avec les Indiens ils peuvent
avoir un des problèmes de connexion par
contre si un problème de connexion on
s'est déjà fait enfler la dernière fois
quand on a joué contre ricaro il y avait
des problèmes connexion
comme ça enfin c'est les règles c'est
comme ça sur internet c'est pas grave
quoi
ouais ouais non mais on verra
mais après ça qui a dit bon mais il me
fait un peu peur
mais là dans ces conditions là il me
fait peur
on verra je sais pas
ouais c'est pas
non mais si on a déjà cette équipe là
avec Max dispo Grisha dispo
mais on joue le matin tu vois
en ce moment ouais machin tu gagnes 2
matchs
mais tu vois c'est comme tu as Bayonne
en ce moment
tout à domicile ils sont très très
chauds
ils défonce tout le monde ils sont très
très chauds mais bon
collaboration avec les supporters du RC
Toulon je savais pas du tout c'est une
chanson qui était une chanson des
Toulonnais je sais pas c'est pas très
connu comme histoire si vraiment pas
Baiona
[Musique]
il est une Pénia la pena Baiona
il porte fièrement partout leur foulard
bleu et blanc
[Musique]
les supporters
parce que il y avait le dirigeant d'un
des groupes de supporters de santé qui
était marié
avec une nana de Bordeaux dont le frère
est le
dirigeant d'un truc et du coup ça a une
famille et ils sont très amis
il y a un supporter de Bayonne qui est
marié avec la sœur de Toulon et
on sait très bien de quoi ça parle
[Musique]
en tout cas
ils sont forts
[Musique]
on parle pas de ça ici
[Rires]
c'est beau qu'on avait les supporters de
Toulon ils viennent c'est une chanson
bon la partie de ça peut quand même
bouger là ils ont une minute chacun on
appuie pas clair le roi blanc est plus
tranquille mais bon
merci 15 de France
le weekend prochain
on Irlande du côté Dublin
à Grenoble grenoblois mais après il
avait pas les mensurations pour jouer en
équipe de France et finalement c'est un
des meilleurs
excellent joueur il joue arrière mais il
peut jouer aussi ailier notamment avec
le Stade Toulousain
pas il adore dame côté nord pas facile à
jouer parce que ça perdait 5 mais ça
clue tout et puis je sais pas cliquer
quoi
après c'est autrement plus dur que le
cahier prend aussi de tout à l'heure
mais bon
4 bah c'est bizarre de donner j'ai 5
mais en fait si tu te dis après tu fais
toi F7 machin tu vas te forcer un dame
prendra mais tu fais des preuves il a
joué
c'est tu mets de la marche avant il faut
bien complètement coincé là-bas dans son
tombeau j'ai envie de dire
[Musique]
mais c'est terminé
il va égaliser peut-être que ça peut
aller en looser Cup pour mcdoche
F4
il pouvait pas faire
dans ma chambre
est-ce que ce serait pas en train de
craquer dame 5 Fuger 7 dame 8
donc c'est nul
peut-être par un dame G6 il y a
peut-être encore fouger 7
et tu tapes
c'est pas fait il faut prendre ma chaîne
qui doit échanger ok donc on a vraiment
un fou bien pourri quoi
il faut réussir à faire un F3 miraculeux
[Musique]
alors fais voir sur ce F quoi trop du
coup
ça devait perdre quand même allez pions
sont quand même plus haut sur
l'échiquier mais oui tu sais pas avec le
clic à la fin
alors est-ce que c'est miskik ou est-ce
que tout d'un coup il a il a oublié
c'est bon on sait jamais mais donc il a
raté ici dame prend des trois il fallait
faire les deux héros H1 c'est pas facile
non c'est pas facile
mais tu contrôles de me prendre des cinq
tu clous et sur un tour F6 tadam prend
des cinq
non c'est dur surtout tu as plus de
temps quoi très difficile donc les amis
on va refaire une petite pause non mais
un truc incroyable
on se retrouve une dizaine de minutes
allez à tout de suite
[Musique]
ça repris de manière hyper étonnante on
est en train de regarder avec femme on
voit les caméras on voit les mecs qui
font du partir prendre parce qu'il y a
décalage sur les sites en fait
et le truc marrant mais du coup en fait
il devait avoir 10 minutes de pause il y
en a pas eu je comprends rien aux
horaires mais en fait soenaca ont déjà
fait nul voilà donc il s'expliqueront
l'armée Guédon et on a irigalisé avec
les Blancs contre Magnus de tourner
comme ça on continue à se mettre de côté
côté
dans ce match vu qu'il y a un ennemi 1
et demi
le joueur qui s'impose se qualifie pour
la suite si jamais il y a nul ça donne
un armaguet donc
bon tout d'un coup
tout d'un coup beaucoup d'enjeux bon
bien que ce ne soit pas éliminatoire
cela dit il y a le double élimination
donc c'est pour retourner dans le looser
que voilà
comme vous voulez
mais dans le Magnus qui était ultra
dominateur en fait et puis petit à petit
domination c'est érodé
partie une il a été impérial partie 2 ça
semble facile bon ça peut être difficile
ça a quand même fait nul mais c'est
passé par une phase plus compliquée la
troisième mais il y a perdu avec les
Blancs
une partie un peu couperait si ça se
passe mal
c'est la période du match quoi donc
donc on va voir vous des 7 jouets donc
ça ne perd pas le pion des 5 parce que
le cavalier E2 en prise en fin de
variante
portant quand même vaut mieux vaut mieux
une position de pions isolés bon je suis
désolé pour longtemps ça me fait sourire
intéressant aussi de laisser les
pourquoi pas mais le plafond de pièces
est légèrement meilleur pour les blancs
quand même avec le cavalier qui peut
venir en F4 voilà attaque un peu d'un
peu des cinq un peu plus
après les Noirs donc ils sont plus en
position défensive avec Sofiane Kios
bon ça devrait aller mais
oui ton dessin peut-être un peu
attaquable
et F4
imprévu
qui était tellement au-dessus on regarde
la première ronde on dit bon bah le son
mais c'est le cas en plus
la deuxième ça a l'air bien se diriger
il a sa petite fille en poche il a tout
connaître et puis en fait non il prend
pas le pion à 4 facilement du tout il
est précise qui peut traîner
puis après il a les blancs quand même
après avoir fait cette nul
il a un carsback il semble être
dominateur et tout d'un coup l'appareil
de côté
et tout d'un coup ça ne va plus
donc j'avais fait 3 étapes le pion
j'imagine va arriver
mais qui avait le cas pour revenir 4
peuvent venir remettre une petite couche
ça va pas être simple
un peu moins bien
un petit peu en souffrance le champion
du monde
mais rien ici qui avait été très
dominant aussi hier
porte la porte la porte la porte la
porte
mais bon déçu par la performance de
Magus
imprévu surtout qu'il y c'est le
souffre-douleur de Magnus depuis un an
que oui Maxime
mais ça pourrait complètement glisser
ok place ces pièces avec les Blancs
plutôt bien
la structure et peut-être récupérer le
pion d'une manière X ou Y
ensuite tout ça
regrette de ne pas participer à cette
proposition il ne pouvait pas il avait
la Bundesliga
c'était samedi et vendredi mais vendredi
il y a une note et oui Maxime
le vendredi c'est ça et donner après
son équipe de Baden-Baden qui continue
pour l'instant le sans faute
devant ton équipe
je suis pas trop ils sont très heureux
quoi
c'est mon équipe
c'est mon équipe j'avais plus trop jouer
pour eux quoi quand tu vas l'équipe
d'isaligne ils ont plus trop besoin de
moi quoi
ils ont besoin de toi en équipe réserve
je sais pas
en équipe 3 en CFA 4 peut-être
c'est pas grand chose en troisième
division qui est montée
80 sponsors et qui s'est mis à être
ambitieux et du coup l'équipe
genre là il y avait même à dire
ok
Google
oui quand tu as des joueurs comme ça tu
as pas besoin de moi quoi
et puis il y a encore de la réserve si
ils veulent tu vois bon et l'équipe 2
l'équipe 2 non l'équipe de je peux
encore avoir ma place mais je vois pas
l'intérêt de blinder une équipe 2 quand
enfin bref mais oui mais madame pour le
coup ça leur fait quand même pas peur
qu'ils étaient équipes en fait ce sera
un match serré mais ils ont fait ils ont
baladé ils ont un rapport
je sais pas si maintenant qu'il est aux
États-Unis mais je pense qu'il est
encore là
je sais plus mais ton gamer ils ont ils
sont très très bien quoi là il t'écrase
en fait ouais mais là tu remets les mecs
comme ça en face
sur un match quand même il y a rien fait
quoi
mais Baden je crois que depuis je sais
pas 2006 2007 c'est plus grand c'est
leur premier titre mais on va dire par
là ils ont gagné chaque année sauf une
fois en 2015 et sinon ça fait 17 ans ou
16 ans que ça dure quoi
c'est pire que le PSG en fait
tous les meilleurs joueurs du monde
d'Europe ou pas non je crois qu'il joue
pas la Coupe d'Europe alors je sais pas
si ils l'ont déjà gagné ou pas mais je
crois qu'il ça les intéresse pas c'est
pas c'est pas dans le projet
il joue vraiment que pour gagner à la
Bundes
ouais
donc c'est avec le fameux
mais ouais donc écoute c'est le gros
gros club allemand donc oui si jamais
une fois fiertime arrive elle est trop
née forcément ça serait très heureux et
ça sera un petit exploit dans le
en plus pour un petit renfort de bail
que des gens à 2007 plus
mais il y a pas de question d'étrangeant
en Allemagne non donc tu peux jouer avec
Maxime peut même se retrouver en plaçant
peut-être pas quand même enfin je sais
pas mais
[Musique]
tu suis en fait enfin moi je suis pas je
m'en fous mais pas bien du tout
tu vois c'est un peu dans un rôle en
rotation quoi rotation active mais
joueurs comme
tout ça qui pareil tu vois enfin
ils te font toute la saison mais c'était
s'il y a un match tu peux les sortir et
ton girofle ils ont ils ont tous les
anciens super fort et ils ont les
nouveaux
tu es très mal là
mais bon c'est pas si évident moi par
exemple j'aurais fait fe et je me dis
oui je suis très con parce que c'est
perdant mais en fait c'est pas évident
non non
elle veut faire quoi
c'est un côté
logique tu gardes la structure
symétrique
sur ton
dessin pour couvrir
et surtout pour l'instant tu as quel F5
qui arrive
F5 il le bouffe et puis voilà
ouais je t'en prie je t'en prie
tu as mis
et on voit le chat bon alors comment
vous savez on a une minute 30 de
décalage on peut pas vraiment répondre
direct dans ce que vous écrivez
pourquoi le top ça je ne m'abuse la
meilleure son cliché alors plus
maintenant alors ça c'est toujours le
meilleur palmarès de France et je veux
pas être médisant c'est le club dans
lequel je joue mais non on n'a pas gagné
le titre depuis un petit moment
en gros tu as plusieurs belles équipes
mais l'équipe qui domine en ce moment
c'est biche Villers
qui viennent il y a un titre je sais pas
combien d'années de suite
quatre peut-être un truc comme ça
après tu as le club de Maxime qui est
pas mal saigner
qui a une belle équipe même sur le
papier probablement qui me favorite mais
ça joue pas grand chose et souvent tu
vois c'est un match série qui change
tout
il y a Chartres qui construit un une
belle équipe avec le maire très
intéressant par les échecs et qui est
une belle équipe voilà
qu'ici qui enfin tu vois on finit sur le
podium un peu régulièrement mais
normalement le titre c'est un peu dur on
sait pas sur un malentendu mais
quand même une marche on va dire
puis tu as des équipes pas mauvaises qui
probablement peuvent pas voir le titre
mais qui peuvent être pénible sur un
match et même sur plusieurs matchs sur
chaque match quoi mais tu as des équipes
comme Mulhouse sont pas mal ta grâce
challon Chalon voilà Chalon belle équipe
etc donc en fait c'est un championnat
serré pas facile
mais il y a pas de grosses armada comme
en Allemagne
tu as des belles équipes mais déjà tu es
obligé d'avoir les Français dans toutes
les réparties un peu et voilà
mais c'est oui tu feras un match même
Villeurbanne c'est pas donné très bien
avec tout le monde
je l'ai reçu quoi
[Musique]
le spectacle
oui ça regarde le match c'est venu faire
des petits câlins
ça demande des câlins
je sais pas ce qui regarde d'autres mais
[Musique]
tu peux aussi prendre trois il prend 8
tu prends des
impression que tu perds
et donc c'est pas un coussin
tu dois pas éviter proche de ton club
pour y jouer
rarement dans les locaux de leur club il
y en a oui bien sûr qui peut être ton
club normalement tu y vas parce que tu
vas tu es content des fois de faire une
visite ou exetera après par des gens qui
sont carrément employés ou qui donne des
cours ou des choses comme ça mais après
dans tes tenues de rien en fait c'est
pas
en fait le chemin de France là aux
échecs le Top 16 c'est sur 11 jours en
fin de saison en juin donc en fait tu
peux habiter où tu veux tu te rends dans
la ville où c'est organisé sur 11 jours
et voilà
en Allemagne c'est déjà plus régulier
c'est c'est un match par un week-end par
mois
donc ça te permet de voir les gens plus
souvent ces deux formats différents bon
voilà
mais en France il y a que la première
division donc le Top 16 qui joue sous ce
format les liens inférieurs enfin la
deuxième division qu'on appelle une
eux ça joue pareil c'est un weekend par
mois et ton histoire de monter descente
comme cette vision laquelle je jouais
quand j'ai rejoint mais ça a demandé de
trop grand déplacement parce que ça joue
le week-end ouais c'est régional mais
c'est original grand en fait on a eu un
match à Toulouse tu vois
un vendredi ou un samedi à Toulouse
un truc dans le coin quoi au pire tu vas
à Nice tu vas aller à monnaie
mais pas oui même quand j'avais rejoint
en National 3 j'avais eu un match à
Vitrolles tu vois
de Cannes c'est loin ouais c'est loin
c'est pas hyper long c'est pas comme
Toulouse évidemment
2h15 retour tu travailles toute la
semaine
qui a gagné le titre avec
ils ont une belle équipe ils prétendent
mais
c'est pas fait enfin c'est il y a de la
concurrence j'ai jamais ça
donc deux clubs on peut être dans autant
de clubs qu'on le souhaite du Mans qui
sont pas dans le même pays tu as des
gens qui cumulent
tu peux jouer dans chaque pays
donc
1 2 3 quoi mais tu peux en avoir plein
qui joue en ligue Espagne
autrichienne légalement et France déjà 4
française je crois que c'est tout mais
voilà il pourrait en rajouter Maxime
aussi dans mon équipe d'Autriche non
pour essayer de décaler et réussir à
arriver avec l'autre tour
si je reviens ici tu fais tourner
c'est qui le coach j'en ai pas vraiment
de coach en fait dans les équipes
d'échec non non après tu as souvent
quelqu'un qui s'en occupe
qui peut être sur le président du club
soit quelqu'un chargé s'occuper de
l'équipe donc Asnières on va dire c'est
plutôt jean-claudemois qui s'en occupe
c'est pas vraiment un coach quoi
très important c'est trop de sponsor
pour avoir entre copier les joueurs
peut-être recruter les joueurs et
vérifier que l'ambiance se passe bien
après les joueurs sont assez forts pour
gérer eux-mêmes choisir quoi jouer ou
quoi prête pour faire une petite réunion
d'équipe après pareil selon les équipes
soit tu fais une sorte de gîte ou tu es
enceinte que la semaine ou tu fais hôtel
et chacun vient de sa life tu dois au
resto et voilà
c'est après chacun fait comme il veut et
quand il préfère moi j'aime bien l'idée
du gîte mais à condition que ça se passe
bien dans l'équipe bien sûr pour le coup
avec Clichy ça se passe très bien enfin
c'est c'est cool mais
il y avait des gros cons
[Musique]
pendant qu'on parle de gîte en train de
mettre la pression donc il a donné un
pion mais bon il attaque quand même bien
E3 il y a les tours sur les colonnes
ouvertes
je sais pas j'essaierai de faire Dame
des 7 plus voir ses dames
ça peut déraper mais oui normalement ça
pourrait vite bien tout échanger
très vite
ça pourrait faire nul
depuis faire un sillon calinou depuis
longtemps oui mais elle est pas bien
avec Sofia et oui tu es pas bien
de la maman
une partie sans histoire ça a tout
échangé en C8 prendre 3 ans
et prendre 3
7 c'était bien joué
ça sent la nuit on va être sur les
armagues et donc ça va être cool
ouais je suis un peu déçu enfin déçu que
la reggaidon soit pas plus rapide en
fait ah bah moi aussi ouais non parce
que ça rajoute
à la fin et c'est pas péchu
quand peut-être leur faire remarquer
heureux de l'innovation d'accord non non
[Musique]
en fait c'est mieux comme ça bah je
pourrais vous dire mais je veux juste
donner mon avis
cette dernière partie
je sais pas pourquoi c'est ça
mais c'est ça qui est difficile quand il
joue dans ses formes là où le speecho
quoi c'est qu'en fait tu as pas le temps
de souffler c'est pas tu as perdu le
lendemain et
pour le coup ah non non mais c'est juste
c'est quelque chose enfin maintenant il
faut savoir l'habitude ça fait des
années qui font mais genre moi j'ai
jamais fait
un mois à part quand on fait les les
machins de cricore ou quoi mais je veux
dire bon j'ai pas l'habitude et ça
change quoi c'est enchaîné
et
pas trop déçu de perdre contre un tel
non
ce serait beau que tu décides d'arrêter
les échecs tu perds
à quoi ça sert de jouer
et
bien joué sur ces deux tours c'est plus
safe
bref on s'en fiche
ça va tenir facile
je m'en occupe
là on est sur du câlin
on est sur du câlin femme
IEN
il faut aussi non elle est un peu
frustrée
mais oui
je pense que je suis de nouveau le
centre du monde
un truc au micro quoi
c'est la plus belle des autres
pour forcer les événements
fin du massage
au sol il faut que je
et ça va faire nul donc ça va partir en
Armageddon on va pouvoir faire une
petite pause avant le dénouement de
cette journée Fab et deux armags
donc ce match là qui a quand même vu
plus de partie décisives une victoire
une défaite de nul et l'autre match avec
donc on se retrouve on va pas se faire à
piéger cette fois-ci on se retrouve à 50
à toute à tout de suite les amis
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs nous sommes de
retour pour l'Armageddon alors attendez
elle est caméras qui se sont redécalées
ou pas
donc je vais mettre
je vais mettre deux et je vais écrire
Armageddon en fait en grand
je pense que je vais je vais je vais
écrire du Armageddon
parce que c'est l'armée en fait
dommage je vais pas les argent décalé
finalement oui
un G2D
mais bon
sons en fait c'est que j'ai déjà écrit
comme toi je crois que je me suis déjà
trompé
pas comme tu le penses mais en fait
c'est dommage je vais faire un truc
aussi long
et de pas avoir les Armageddon en décalé
finalement oui oui c'est dommage
c'est soit long des Armageddon
et tu dis bah on les dégages comme ça on
peut assister aux deux moments
décalé
et de pas de d'avoir les armags en même
temps
ce que je crois que depuis la troisième
division là je crois que ça fait 10 ans
que ça a commencé la sur la journée
[Rires]
il en veut plus quoi
il doit pas être bien par hame allez ça
part
ça part Fab avec 10 minutes contre 13
allez on va voir ce qui se passe
cavalier F3 qui est ici ça taxe ça
défend tous ces quatre est-ce qu'il y a
du kg 5 qui parlent non des trois ça
joue le Juke au piano
comprends pas c'est que la pendule
marche pas il faut 7 mais si la pendule
marche pas ouais mais c'est parce que il
y a ouais ils ont fait une petite
erreur peut-être
alors on va oh ils ont laissé le rajout
ils ont laissé le rajoutez la partie
arrêtez tous les amis ah ouais mais bon
alors peut-être qu'il y a un jour winner
et qu'il aurait ici
en tout cas sinon c'est pas
réglementaire il y a un vrai souci enfin
j'en sais rien armage
[Musique]
s'est arrêté mesdames et messieurs il
Caou en a marre Magnus aussi régaler
tout le monde en a marre
qui fait des signes ouais qui rigolent
comment c'est possible mais bon
attention il carotte quand même il Caron
qui se barre on le voit pas la noix à
l'écran mais il est en train de se
barrer le frérot
désabusé et carreaux
j'ai quasiment envie de faire un TikTok
scandale dans le jeu d'échec
international les arbitres se trompent
Fab hein ouais c'est ouais karaoké ko
qui sert la main dans la tête et dégoûté
il devait être complètement gagnant déjà
et Magnus est-ce qu'il va rejouer au 5
ouais mais moi j'aurais été une belle
enflure j'aurais pas fait les carouki il
le sait et qui aurait ouais Magnus ça
rejoue pareil
ils ont laissé le rajout de temps
regarde si ça roule pas est-ce qu'on a
les couilles de la partie d'avant
et ouais il est énervé désabusé le soir
américain désolé on a pas sa caméra
malheureusement
est-ce que est-ce que je tente de vous
montrer un peu Hikaru on le voit plus
non là il est plus il était désabusé il
était absolument
furax
et ouais mais quand tes joueurs Fabien
comment gérer comme ça des erreurs
d'arbitrage quand même à ce niveau de la
compétition 2 et finale du Racing master
car enfin un peu mal demi-finale de
arbitrage assez énormes comme ça comment
tu gères les émotions la femme quand tu
es joueurs
se concentrer sur ce que toi tu es
capable de gérer ce que tu contrôles et
pas c'est pas le reste mais c'est vrai
que l'échecs on est habitué
quand même d'habitude
quand ils influence généralement il y a
des dingueries quand même des méthodes
enfin des fois bon mais
est quand même grand c'est un circuit de
tournoi il y a 2 millions de dollars de
prix sur des séminés sur sur à peine une
trentaine de jours de jeux c'est des
prix qui sont colossaux absolument
colossaux on est là donc dans un match
même important
à faire progresser les arbitres du coup
pour arbitrer une telle compétition et
oui oui parce que là c'est vrai que
l'enjeu est tel que ouais on a vu
Ricardo malheureusement on n'avait pas
la caméra ici sur lui mais on l'a vu
vraiment sur les écrans de contrôle de
multiples gestes d'aînés d'énervement
d'accassement genre américain qui s'est
remis mais s'il venait à se faire
éliminer
ce serait ce serait quand même quand
même compliqué non c'est ça que
naïvement tu te dis bon ça joue sur
Internet faut pas dire qu'il est Go
normalement l'arbitrage n'ira pas de
problème et voilà en fait
qui ont laissé les trois secondes dans
l'Armageddon après à la décharge les
arbitres le le règlement est très
compliqué il y a beaucoup de points de
règlement et c'est vrai que c'est pas si
facile de tout faire respecter mais là
on a vu à Hikaru qui devait avoir obtenu
ce qui souhaitait dans l'ouverture pour
être aussi énervé
ou alors on part par principe c'est
ouais en tout cas c'est incroyable
Magnus qui est sorti de cette ouverture
donc il a 5 minutes de moins il peut
faire nul avec les noirs pour gagner il
y a ici qui va essayer d'éviter d'aller
jouer contre son compatriote goût cache
ouais
qui est bouillant attention c'est lui
qui a gagné le tournoi qualificatif
ouais il est assez impressionnant et
aujourd'hui contre ma médaf malgré qu'il
est raté une partie il est bien revenu
dedans donc on va vouloir éviter d'aller
jouer bookage côté Magnus pareil un
indien peut en cacher un autre
oui après l'Indien du placard pourrait
faire mal sortir et beau film
attention la foule 3 ça se développe en
tout cas ouverture réussie pour le
moment pour minus qui qui a qui a
égalisé qui peut jouer peut-être un
petit peu comme douboff avec du damage 5
tours F7 Tour Eiffel 8 il aime bien
Daniel mais là il préparait peut-être
plutôt des cinq en surprotégeant le pion
E5 mais je vois bien une dame dans la
partie en naviguer là
et tout rêve 7 tours est fui dame G6 un
peu le même plan enfin
les blancs
oh là là la gaffe qui est juste là pour
être faite tour point F3 femme est-ce
que tu penses là ce qu'une erreur comme
ça et possible il y a quand même déjà 4
heures de jeu entre les deux hommes
quasiment ils sont fatigués ils sont é
rincés ouais ça peut ça peut un terrain
c'est de peu arrivé pour toi bon je
pense pas mais
bon
slip tu me dis ça un peu
S3 et c'est terminé voilà donc
Magnus là qui crée un danger un clouage
il est cloué il crée le danger on va
voir est-ce que Erika ici a les mains
encore sèches et si j'ai pas vu de talc
on a pas vu le tag et pourtant pareil il
faudrait qu'on s'asser ce genre de
détail mais ça peut aider pour bien
tenir la souris en main
qui semble réaliser la partie parfaite
peut-être
pas glisser de manière éliminatoire j'ai
envie de dire peut-être j'ai un coup de
courage de profilaxie contre le mossip
ça c'est joli cours anticipe
H6 tempo
est-ce qu'ils sont tenus de rester
les caméras allumées je sais pas
vraiment de quoi ils sont tenus
enfin miroir
pas de Talk mais du coup un petit roi H1
ça mange pas de pain
c'est bien joué
et c'est qui
je sais pas quoi
il y a des petites photos de hockey
dans le pays des bras
pourquoi en fait il y avait des enchères
parce que celui qui allait noir a le
droit de faire nul
et donc c'est celui qui a décidé d'avoir
le moins de temps qui qui allait noir
décision
très logique contre Wesley pour le coup
de nuls et forcer les noirs et plutôt
logique une minute
qui prend à 5 cavalier prend
et c'est 4
ça clique côté ici
dubitatif pour le moment le joueur
indien
d'après même une défaite dans cet arc à
magadon n'est pas éliminatoire après on
soit je suis pas convaincu de son choix
d'ouverture
trop mou non non
en fait elle est chercher Magnus sur le
cadre 5 c'est
que tu joues au 4 il fait
il a pas fait dans les parties avant
accepter donc il faisait plutôt des
quatre
et donc en haut de 5 minutes d'avance tu
peux essayer de faire je sais pas quoi
moi mais tu
t'en fous tu te fais il aimait bien
faire des quêtes qui essaie trois fois
Fiat là un truc un peu sans théorie bon
à ce niveau-là
tellement fort mais ils sont en général
dessus que
il y a du rabattre quoi elle est en
train de se faire retourner comme une
crêpe ils sont nombreux à te casser les
dents dessus quoi
et donc je sais pas bizarre quoi
tu as envie de se tester ouais enfin
cruciale
un gros enjeu pour cette heure-là quand
même donc
peut-être mauvaise stratégie il y a
quand même beaucoup d'argent à la clé
mais attention il y a peut-être le
cavalier D7 en ligne de mire
en tout cas il y a ici c'est la première
fois que je le vois au temps tenir tête
à Magnus oui ça peut le rassurer pour la
suite de la saison
parce que les deux hommes
se recroiseront probablement des
événements le prochain dès avril
d'ailleurs du français juste avant le
match Championnat du Monde
l'événement que toi malheureusement tu
ne pourras pas commenter en ma compagnie
Fab alors peut-être la finale ou quoi
mais avant je joue l'Open de Reykjavik
pour cette compétition mais bon j'espère
qu'il y aura vite
une autre manche peut-être au mois de
mai ou quelque chose comme ça et que je
pourrais voir la suite quoi
ouais ouais donc il a fait
attention de pas se prendre un perpète
avec un genre de fou des si c'est un
chantage à nul
on peut montrer la variante
[Musique]
F3 dame français
oui bon rien de grave mais il y a
perpète
ce qui est très grave puisque nul gagne
pour
pour les noirs
à la maison tour D8 et donc il laisse
d'un Français 4 pour faire le schéma de
nul dans ton vous parler c'est ça
il y a tellement de nuls aux échecs
c'est quand même un énorme avantage de
pouvoir jouer pour nul et je reste
dubitatif sur une cadence lente en avant
ça favorise normalement en fait tu fais
un truc tu joues le flag quoi c'est bon
donc c'est au joueur après d'ajuster
leur enchères
moi c'est plus sur le côté bon les
matchs
5 que les deux sont en même temps après
c'est une question de goût
en tout cas ça se passe extrêmement bien
pour Magnus qui devrait se diriger en
finale se propose juste qu'on jette un
oeil furtif sur la position du carreau
entre carreaux et os les sauts
[Musique]
et peut-être dans la merde
parce que ce pion H3 est fort donc là
ouais les soins avec les pièces blanches
on devrait changer beaucoup faire
tourner tranquillement
on reviendra après mais il semble petit
carreau et la main ça devrait vite finir
côté
un peu
on sait pas à quoi sert le looser vu que
tu as de la finale tu dois avoir en fait
bon toujours est-il Magnus qui a rien en
plus mais qui a le bon tandem Torfou qui
peut créer un pion passé à la dame
il est beaucoup mieux et Caro je vois sa
tête que ça a l'air
de très bien se passer vous voyez on
peut pas voir de toutes les caméras mais
ouais ok
[Rires]
qui va qui va s'imposer Magnus aussi
je vois pas comment irriguer ici peut
gagner ça
espérer des choses improbables
après ces bug sur déco
remplace son fond c'est 5 pourquoi pas
ils font bien
[Musique]
en fait c'est juste que tu
il ferme les coups en fait
c'est dur quoi
[Musique]
c'est le pire
comme si tu dois jouer contre Nadal et
folle battre et tu rat tiens battu ben
non on va ailleurs et puis ça se traduit
quand même mais bon ça y est quoi
attendez on voit je voyais Caro un peu
nerveux sur la cam on va juste rejeter
un oeil sans rechanger tout
écoute on peut peut-être aller voir
l'autre match changer les caméras en
express
on va se mettre côté
un peu dégueu
les priorités au direct je vais pas
changer les noms j'imagine que vous
reconnaissez les joueurs on va essayer
de suivre la fin de la partie
avec Hikaru
avec les noirs qui peut se contenter de
faire match nul
qui a un pion de moins mais bon déjà et
surtout l'Interactive en E2 avec ce pion
H3 qui peut s'arrête super et si jamais
il peut doubler mais ça serait génial
c'est d'ailleurs sûrement le but de qui
est ici de pas essayer de tourger de
Tournes
et là il a du mal ouais ouais
à générer de l'activité on va dire la
différence c'est que
s'il devait faire nul il est arrivé
mais tu vas faire tourner
5 et essayer de faire ça
c'est con
on prend à 5 il veut quoi je sais pas
trop compris pourquoi 5 mais bon
pourquoi pas enfin en fait j'ai pas
compris le coup en fait
jusqu'ici
ça va être un problème
on va retourner des petites têtes
sur Carlson on va on va enlever les
cames parce qu'on voit bien que les
trésors que les joueurs sont qualifiés
en plus la décams
il devrait faire nul désolé pour le
cadrage des cas moi ça va bouger et
c'est pour ça que je les ai carrément
alors attends
et ça va faire nul et donc Armageddon
gagné par les noirs et ça veut dire
qu'on aura une première finale de la
winner cue entre
surprise no surprises comme les
américains exactement mais donc
bonnes sont pas vraiment éliminaires ils
vont retourner dans l'autre
loser bracket et
demi finale voilà et ils auront donc un
match
en 2007
à mon avis j'imagine demain peut-être
mais en deux parties
et comme ça jeudi ils font la finale des
perdants pour se qualifier contre le
grand vainqueur
donc demain est-ce que ça décale les
matchs
c'est décalé c'est décalé
de faire avancer leur bracade à eux
aussi
qu'on aura les autres vraiment
jouera le Carlson Naka honnêtement c'est
pas facile de le connaître parce qu'en
fait nous on a le truc ça joue à 17h
tous les jours mais on se rend compte
que quel match commence quand c'est pas
c'est réellement pas écrit sur les trucs
de brief que j'ai pu lire c'est
peut-être sur d'autres trucs de brief
mais il y a tellement d'informations de
règles de
se renseigner on vous mettra les infos
sur sur notre Twitter respectifs
peut-être ou si jamais on les a
aujourd'hui j'ai pas j'ai pas eu l'info
j'ai dû la rater elle devait être
quelque part c'est un faux mais bon tu
peux pas tu peux pas
de pages de brief faire les castes les
régimes c'est pas simple du coup nous on
va pas se on va on va pas se quitter
complètement
puisqu'on va aller voir puisqu'on va
voir Baki
je peux faire le raid parce que je crois
pas que je sois connecté
avec avec James com mais de toute façon
vous savez vous savez où nous trouver je
vais mettre le lien par principe
je vais mettre
et on va mettre les clips
mais ouais donc ça donc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui et je vais vous mettre le
lien si vous voulez suivre Étienne Bacro
donc dans un peu moins de trois quarts
d'heure
l'équipe vont déjà partie
OK
à demain
pour la suite du tournoi ciao ciao
[Musique]